Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Anyway, whoa!
Hey everybody Oh my god, sorry, I had to push back the
stream a little bit earlier Cause I like, I woke up and it
was like Work
It was just like Ducky, work messages And I was like
I was just like
So I had to I had to push back the stream a little bit
Because I had to I had to deal with work stuff Oh my god
Every day is so So so so busy It's been a busy busy Busy
time for me Um But yeah oh Whoa whoa whoa whoa for you those
who don't follow me my twitch adventures we got third place
plus one third place plus one in in in the pow pow world
twitch rivals yeah top three plus one spoiler for those who
were waiting for the vods um i did make a VOD channel.
I linked it on my YouTube channel, but I do have a VOD
channel now.
I'm so sorry for spoiling the people who are waiting for me
to upload it onto VODs.
I'm so sorry, but at least you can we'll be able to watch.
You don't know how we got top three, you know?
You don't know how we got top three, so you can watch the
process of all of it happening.
It's not like I tweeted it out that I got top three and
everything
um but yeah I want to say a huge thank you for uh the people
at Twitch for inviting me and everything you know what was
crazy like uh afterwards they actually I'm pretty sure I can
talk about it
talk about it because it's like still in the early, like
they literally like asked me if I was like interested but
like Twitch was like do you want to like headline a Twitch
rivals?
I was like huh?
I was like me?
Yeah they asked me they were like do you want to like you
know how like Twitch rivals was like Twitch rivals beat
Piratesop who organized the Twitch rivals for Power World?
You know how that like the Fortnite beat ex fortnite creator
whatever they were like do you want to like do on your own
and i was like fuck yeah what me i'm just a little old indie
vtuber like i was so i was so fucking uh surprised but yeah
like i don't know you just wanted to answer and i was like
sweet yeah i don't know what i'll be doing when that sounds
pretty fucking cool um but yeah like a a huge shout out to
like twitch for the huge support i was so i was so surprised
like honestly it's been like super overwhelming every day i
would say it's been it's been incredibly overwhelming um
seeing all these like companies and like sponsors and stuff
like reaching out and stuff being like do you do you want to
do this and I was like me you want me to do this
but then I've been like super stressed out because like I's
like I've never had chance to like handle with the money of
everything too because like I have a team now and then like
my manager was start talking about like payroll and like
like money and I'm like Money I was like pay payroll
So i was just like what what what do i what do i what do i
i'm a i'm a boss i'm a i'm a boss now but but like i i just
do i just i just i just do i don't what do you mean payroll
i i'm so confused
so um it's like so like like you are the boss now toky no i
just want something to take care of me i just i just want to
do I just I just want to do I don't want it I don't want to
think about payroll and money I just want you I I organized
things money disappears I don't look at it but now I have to
look at it I was like no I have to look at the money I don't
I all I want to do is just do like that's all I want to do I
just organize and do fun things and I don't think about the
money and now now mr.
man was like it's time to talk serious adult time with
payroll like money-wise have budgeting finances I was like
uh interns, payroll, staff, PR team, management team, store
team, sponsor.
See, I was like, I was just like, no, being an adult is so
hard.
PJ, thank you for the Aka Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
you for bringing joy to so many people and becoming a
stronger person you deserve your success thank you i really
appreciate it thank you taxes contracts a lawyer to help
with help with like like sponsor like drafting up ndas i'm
like drafting up ndas
i was like oh my god
You're like, you need a Canadian lawyer because you're
Canadian, so you're trapped that handles like business
lawyer stuff with MDAs.
So I'm like, ah.
I'm just like, oh no.
Anyway, so that was like last night and today.
What does that mean?
I know.
like like mr man would send me like a whole bunch of
information last night and then they're and then they're
like and now i was just like i'm going to sleep
mr man mr man sent me like a bunch of information and i was
like because like at first they were like are you alive and
i was like yes and he sent me like a ton of information like
it's like I'm gonna sleep
Future Doki will worry about that later Future Doki will
worry about this Another time It was like I can't I'm sorry
I'm so tired I can't I cannot make any decision Right now
and then I woke up And then it was like And I'm just like
read.
I was like, on read.
Okay, stream time.
Um, super persona gamer.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
Um, hey, Doki, I'm celebrating my birthday today.
Can you sing when everything stays?
No, but I'll sing happy birthday.
I guess I don't know what you're talking about.
Thank you for the Akasu.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear.
Super Persona Gamer.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Man, you'll end up becoming your own agency at this point.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Atlas, I'm sorry for Future Tokyo.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
actually tempted to like because like when I saw the like
giant paragraphs of like information and stuff I had to do
yesterday last night I was like oh fuck should I like push
back today's stream and I was just like no I really want to
stream I want to run away from my responsibilities for one
more afternoon
that's like so i'm just like no i i will stream i'll run
away from my responsibilities and pretend that i don't have
to do all of that later yay procrastinate please don't be
like me please please do not be like me procrastination is a
bad thing okay guys just i just i just need this I I really
I really need this guy I really fucking need this
Alright, anyway Aaron anyway, like I am the example of
things you should not do I am I'm basically like I'm
teaching you what not to do guys What the fuck?
Why doesn't my controller not working?
Do I have to restart fuck?
Okay, guys, sorry I have to restart my game because I
accidentally went on M&K instead of controller and I have
not learned how to play this game on mouse and keyboard.
She's just, no, you don't want to be just like me for real,
for real.
You have to be, she's just not like me for real, for real.
Uh, JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, delicious.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Boy, do I get running away from responsibility?
No, do not run away from responsibility.
It is bad.
It is so bad right like right now.
I'm trying to pretend I don't have all these
responsibilities and it's very bad It is very very bad guys
Guys, this is not good.
It's not good.
Okay I'm here.
I'm the I'm here to teach you guys how not good this is All
right here and maybe this time I'll have controller beam
plugged in come on batman why can't i just be a billionaire
so i never have to care about payroll
if i was a billionaire i'll have so much fucking money that
i won't even care they'll be like they won't they can like
basically they'll like write down that i'm paying them like
a hundred k an hour and i wouldn't care i only have 24 i
played five hours 24% but anyway if I was a billionaire I
would not have to care about payroll because they can
literally write a hundred K a day or some shit and I won't
care Because I'll make back a hundred K in a day like they
can do whatever the fuck they want But sadly I'm just an
anime girl
I'm just an anime girl I can't care I have to actually care
Where am I supposed to go?
We're in the tunnel?
Whoa!
Oh, shit, he has a gun.
I remember how I'll play.
No!
Shit!
It's okay.
He can't kill me forever.
Oh, they all have guns.
Oh, never mind.
No!
My one weakness.
Guns.
It's okay.
It's all right.
I did realize they all had guns.
Oh, guys, look at this.
There's no flashes now.
You see that?
Because I can run mods.
Shout out to that one dragoon that linked me, like, the mods
thing, where it actually disables flash.
Oh, shit.
Give me back up.
Get me up there.
There's no flashbang anymore.
Thank fucking God.
Holy shit.
A dragoon linked me to a mod that, like, basically disables,
like, all the flashbangs, and, thank fucking God.
Oh, my God.
I'm so happy.
Wee.
There's no way I can miss.
Please don't look up.
Guys, no, this is...
Guys, I just need you guys to know.
This is very strategic because I purposely made them all
together, so it's, like, bowling again.
please please okay wait wait I'm lining them up guys I'm
lining them up everybody okay they're all perfectly lined up
now and like okay here you here you go I swear to fucking I
swear oh shit oh no please Okay, all right, now, now they'll
be perfectly lined up.
Watch this.
It's like bowling.
There's no way.
I...
No, I don't know anymore.
No!
I thought you'd last long.
Look, look, I'm, is it a bad time to tell you guys that I'm
not very good at bullying?
Is that, Hunter, thank you for this super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Is it, is it a bad time to admit that I was never good at
bullying?
Bullying is a lot harder than expected.
Bullying is just, bullying is just as hard as our IRA.
Okay, this time.
There's no way.
At least let me hit one guy.
Like, that's all I asked for.
Please don't look up.
I swear to God.
Wait, how did he get up so fast?
I don't understand.
I swear to God.
I hate this game.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna...
Okay, we're gonna do stealth mode.
I might be able to stealth this.
Oh.
It's stealth.
It's almost stealth.
I did it, guys.
Oh, it was that easy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Finally a streamer that isn't too lazy to install mods It's
not that we're too lazy to install mods is that we're not
allowed to because it's a mod Because then we would have to
like ask like a lot of times people are like it's a mod it
modified the games And usually it wouldn't they would if
they would be like no
I'm my own boss.
I don't have to ask anybody.
Look, see, I can stealth.
I got this.
I was like, uh, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Here.
I don't know where to go.
Where am I supposed to go?
Why is there your question marks?
Look, hit the tomato soup.
Ah, beam.
Thank you for this.
Akasupa set.
Okay.
Thank you.
Wait, what are these question marks?
Are these all the rhythm-y-disc shit?
It must be.
What's this?
Warden's mansion.
Obtain destroy.
Obtain the security key codes from the warden.
Locate the wardens.
Did I...
Did I not have the security key?
What the fuck was I doing?
Wait, did I Did I get the security key?
I don't remember.
Find, locate.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I just need to find the...
Okay, I'm just gonna follow the bloodstains.
Alright.
Here I go.
Is there anybody here?
Oh, shit.
No don't.
He'll might be into it.
Okay.
Oh, the TV.
Oh, damn it, it was too late.
That's too late for the spanking.
God damn it.
Oh,
my God.
God damn it.
That's too distracted.
All right, let's go.
We gotta find the warden.
Here we go.
Oh, those are...
I...
I like...
I've been...
I was like thinking about...
Wait, who's that?
Oh, he- is he dead?
I- Off it goes.
Maybe I'll find somebody randomly.
You know what?
I crashed the game.
Guys, it went too far.
It's just too- The batter ranch traveled way too far guys
the batter it went beyond its scope it went too far out of
bounds six thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you doki is truly a scattered brain verb thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you oh my god it traveled out
of game they're like you can't do this yeah batter i was
never meant to travel this far Yeah, it went so far.
I just quit the game.
It went further.
It went further beyond.
Oh my god.
Did you guys hear that, like, they wanted to make a Batman
Beyond animated film in the same, from the same studios that
did the Spider-Verse movies?
And then Warner Brothers was like, no.
Like, they had, like, like, they drafted, like, storyboards
and everything.
And then Warner Brothers was like, no, yeah, I was looking
at the artwork for it.
It looked so good.
That is so bad.
Oh, that's why there's wheelchairs everywhere.
Oh.
Okay, where is these fingerprints going this way?
Yeah, Warner.
I mean, like, I'm honestly not surprised because Warner
Brothers has been like, you know shelving a lot of stuff
down so like are you guys really surprised though that this
side is shelving they've been like shelving a lot of
projects in general so it's not like the first time i can
just you've done nothing but wine since we got busted out
yeah joker sends his girlfriend down and tells us to guard
the tunnel joker tells us to kill the bat we kill the fat
Did you do it?
Funny thing, he said the same to me.
I told him I ain't even have a sister.
He just kept telling me to do it.
So I got in my car.
What the fuck?
Bro, you could have just killed a random girl.
Kind of a mystery, you know.
I mean, don't get me wrong, but he acts all crazy one minute
and then the next, these old plans and jobs.
Who knows what goes on here?
Bro, that guy came just killed a random girl instead of his
sister.
He doesn't care.
He just hates women, I guess.
Again.
There's one.
There's no way.
Come on.
No!
Fuck!
Okay, I'm gonna go in.
Whoa!
There's no way!
You!
No!
Get me.
Get me out of here.
Okay.
There you go.
It's fine.
I just needed to get rid of guns oh god okay it's fine I
still remember how to dodge I just got rid of the guns okay
no gun ow it's okay I can reach it no how are you getting
guns again that's illegal picking up a gun from the floor
that's so insane If I can't pick up a random gun on the
floor, you can't either.
Because they can pick up.
No, if it touches the floor, it's like a five second rule.
And five seconds is already gone.
So, like, what's the point of having a five second rule if
they can just pick up a gun after five seconds?
Like, come on.
That's not fair.
Like, the floor is like, exactly.
All right, let me...
Let me fucking tag this This wall real quick Boop They're
gonna need this Yeah, they don't want to get gun cooties
That's how you get cooties
Sweet, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you I
work too much But being here is more important Who need No,
you sleep Sweet, don't worry There's always the bud Sleep is
very important important i still haven't fixed my sleep
schedule it's been like two weeks i still haven't fixed it
guys remember to backseat me for the riddles i'm too stupid
to solve this right now this is why bat you know what i
noticed i noticed that all of batman's robins have like
black hair so like it's not random
i've noticed it the kids he's adopting it's not random he's
got a type
whoa he's got a type yeah there was the red hair yeah but
like we who we don't really think about that person
he had in pre-crisis yes but then he died his because he
realized he wasn't he wasn't the favorite he realized he
wasn't he wasn't I'm having a conversation I'm so sorry whoa
where the fuck did I get shot at as I was saying he realized
he realized that you know he wasn't getting the same
treatment as the other Robins I mean He was literally the
first one to die.
So, like, at this point, like, wow.
The robin that doesn't have black hair dies?
That's what a coincidence.
Yeah, it was so rude.
Where am I supposed to go?
I need to...
I already lost the trail.
I was in a lot looking at the trail.
Where is it?
Oh, shit.
Where's the DNA?
Oh, there it is.
There's where it goes.
I'm so happy it doesn't have flashbang anymore.
I hated that shit so much.
This way.
Okay, there it is.
Oh, it has...
Oh, the structural weakness.
Does it really matter if I...
Oh, wait, I can collapse this structure.
Alright.
Woo!
How do you not hear that?
Oh, that doesn't matter.
It was just lore.
I returned to my work, but I could not shake the pictures
from my mind.
I should have been repulsed, but I was more eager than ever
to find an explanation for why someone would do this.
Oh, okay.
You know they don't have guns.
I can just beat them up.
I actually wonder if the Joker actually provides insurance.
Do you guys think the Joker would provide insurance?
Because like, I feel like being a henchman is like, like
such a, like, it's like literally the only job I feel like.
No?
He could be a good employer.
You don't know that.
Joe, not a chance.
He could be a good employer.
Okay, let me get...
Oh, shit, no!
Okay, counter him.
Gotta get this guy...
Get out.
Okay, get him out first.
Like, he pays his taxes.
Okay, if he pays his taxes, he could be paying insurance.
But to be fair, he does employ a lot of henchmen.
So that is a lot of insurance.
Does he offer a 401k?
Oh, yeah!
Wait, you're alive?
Oh, there...
Oh, okay, he's just gonna jog off.
Bro, I don't think that guy's alive, though.
I don't think he's alive.
Alright, which one do we upgrade, guys?
Combo boost, combo batterang, HP, batteram power, twin
batterams, Sonic batterams.
Okay, these are not available for upgrade.
great i don't think oh wait they are nice take down batter m
combo boost okay combo boost joker pace spikes potion neil
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'll get
the combo boost
are you okay the guard wouldn't have lasted much longer is
he okay he struck his head when they knocked him to the
ground oh no away from here as soon as you can take him to
the medical It's the safest place on the island.
I like being a henchman has to be like the most lucrative
job there is in Gotham City.
Like there's so many henchmans.
Like there's so many mob bosses too.
It's like, it's like the only job in Gotham City.
Think about it.
I just noticed it's literally like the only job.
Like this entire town is controlled by the mob.
And it's just like, I think the police is useless.
Why be a cop when he can just be a fucking, like, underling?
There's no reason to be...
Why be paid, like, minimal wage as a cop when you can be...
Why be paid, like, $11 for an hour for a cop when you be
paid, like, I don't know, like, a hundred bucks per hour
because you're always going on heist and everything.
Boop.
nice i did that no don't grab the gun no i can't run no
don't pick up the gun no oh he's not picking up the gun he
knows that he respects the five second rule oh i just punted
him that's nice see i told you i told you oh no no no no
that's more than five seconds all right let's get him out i
need He doesn't come back.
Oh yeah, you think about it.
Batman is sort of like a furry.
Because he's wearing a...
He's wearing an outfit inspired by a bat.
Why is the junk...
Junkling obsessed with man and bat?
Is he a furry?
Thank you.
Oh shit, my chat.
God, give me a sec.
I need to reload my chat.
He has bat ears.
Yeah.
And he likes Catwoman!
Catwoman is definitely a furry.
If you think about it.
$9 billion fursuit.
No, but you don't understand!
Like, fursuits actually are, like, a fucking so expensive.
And he's a billionaire, too!
It fits him.
Alright.
Where am I going?
Oh, okay, that's locked.
Okay.
Wait, what's the riddle?
I don't remember what the riddle was in this area.
Guys, where is the riddle?
Where is the riddle?
I don't know what the riddle was.
I don't remember the riddle.
There's a tape?
Where's the tape?
Tape?
There's no tape here.
You fucking liars.
where the fuck is the tape oh it's near the entrance okay
don't worry i won't miss the lore oh yeah do you know
there's lore on why he wears his underwear outside of his
suit i know they have lore for everything who's this
okay but like 20 is like nothing in gotham at this rate
Anything that does matter is the mark.
Have you seen my work, Miss Cassidy?
What the fuck is this guy?
This is actually a villain I don't know.
He's important enough to have, like, only voice file, but
I'm like, what the fuck is this guy?
Anyway, so the reason why Batman wears his underwear outside
of his, like, superhero suit is that it acts as, like, a
filtration device.
I don't remember if it was like gas or whatever, but like he
can use it to, he can take, so he can take his underwear off
very fast and use it as like a filtration thing.
Yeah, yeah, like to like, to like, you know, put it, put it
over his mouth to filter stuff.
And I don't, it's obviously bullshit that they invented
later on, but like, that's like the current lore as to why,
that's the why he wears underwear.
Outside of his like suit it's obvious it's like they
invented it just for like as like a bullshit reason But
that's like the canon reason why he fucking wears his
underwear It's like a gas mask.
Yeah, it's like apparently a fucking like it's it's
apparently a gas mask All right, is there anybody here?
I want to be sure there's anybody here.
Okay Is there anything in here?
What's the sauce for this?
YouTube shorts is always YouTube shorts.
I thought, real soft.
How do you reflect on your successes and failures, Batman?
I don't.
If I don't think about it.
If I never think about it, then I'll never feel guilty.
Yeah, next time I'll be stuck in deadly gas, I'll use my
underwear.
Exactly!
We're all learning.
Hello.
Ooh, I don't like two people, one voice, no gun.
Two face?
Ow!
Wait, what's going on over there?
Is this a laughing gas?
What's going on?
What the fuck is going on?
What the fuck?
Is everything okay?
Is...
What the fuck is...
What?
What is going on?
Oh, this doesn't look too good.
Are they okay?
Wait, how did you die?
They're all locked up.
Return to monkey.
Holy shit, what's going on?
Okay, there's the electricity.
I wonder if there's like anything extra up top.
Is there anything, any loot?
I know there's like a party going downstairs, but loot
supplies can only be used only in a breakout attempt.
This is important.
This is the breakout attempt.
There might be stuff here.
Teeth!
Alright.
Nope.
Can't activate that yet.
Oh.
Tape to patient evaluation 5.
is not responding victor yesterday we spoke about the people
you killed ah the zombies they are all people victor they
are zombies continuously shuffling through the daily grind
waiting for someone to liberate them you mean kill them the
police report states that you've murdered oh it's 20 20
people in the three months that's like nothing in gotham the
joker murdered like 50 people a day he
should be like in the like the prison like these not should
not be an arkham asylum i could sound this word like the
grade a villains like rookie numbers exactly it's okay how
do you know where i get yeah
he has such a fucking low body count
he is not he is not fit He's not Arkham Asylum Material.
This is why nobody remembers him.
20 people in like three months.
Like, if I was allowed to kill, I'm pretty sure I've killed
like 100 today.
It's still...
The thing is, like, it might have been like one week since
we started playing this game.
But, like, all right now, like, for Batman, it's still,
like, maybe two hours have passed for Batman.
Batman and like if we're going by Batman time if I was
allowed to kill him in Batman I'm pretty sure I've killed a
hundred people in Batman within two hours in Arkham aside
I'm just saying I'm so I just like who the fuck cares about
mr.
Zaz why the fuck do we put him in like the grade a the grade
a um asylum oh wait is this it oh now this is too small
there you go two people one voice one that has to be too oh
that's a ventricle request i know that was a timid orphan
whose deep regression erupted in a barren bra resulting in
him being sent to a black gate prison there he encountered a
puppet scarface and oh yeah he's like a mob bob son or
something and probably murdered inseparable with a scarface
directing a series of criminal activities while most believe
that wesker is simply acting out a second personality
through the puppet wesker sees himself as a reluctant lackey
who merely does his parents biddy what was this what's his
size what's his height five foot seven professional criminal
nice oh wait he has facts wait i want to know about his life
all right delusional schizophren oh he didn't take his meds
obsessed with his puppets Scarface, whom he puppeteers with.
This...
Wait.
We just have a mental health problem in Gotham City.
When Teen was...
If we give the criminals, like, actually meds, do you think
they'll be better?
Batman!
You could have stopped on this if you improved the mental
health system!
In Gotham City!
Instead of running around in your underwear!
And buying underwear gas masks!
all right i guess we leave here probably not who needs
youtube shorts for batman lore i use doki batman's cheese
for getting the lord gozina thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you he is gothams biggest serial killer
after yeah yeah he's definitely gothams biggest serial
killer after joker gozina super chat cs thank you thank you
oh is that poison ivy Ivy!
Stop!
Really not interested in a bunch of flowers, Ivy.
They're in pain!
Cry for help!
Ooh!
Where are your babies?
Just stay where you are.
Last thing I need is you running out.
Just stay- How is she gonna get out?
I'll save you.
Just stay where you are.
Like, she's- Where is she gonna go?
Botanus, Pamela, Isla.
was transformed by a science experiment gone wrong into a
plant-human hybrid.
When chlorophyll flowing through her veins instead of
bloods, she developed a toxic touch and a pheromone-fueled
talent for seduction.
Her crimes have become more ecologically focused as she has
increasingly abandoned her human side, identifying more with
the natural world.
Her unique brand of eco-terrorism often puts her in a
conflict with Batman, whose iron will usually protects him
from her seductive powers.
It's just not hot enough, I guess.
It's just not his type.
Five foot.
Wait, she's taller than the ventriloquist.
An ability to encourage and direct the growth of all plant
life.
Plant G is mixed into her DNA.
Makes her an unpredictable and formidable physical opponent.
Exudes natural hormones that enable her to exert control
over victims.
Are you crying?
Wait, why is she wearing a shirt?
I mean, I meant that in a way where, like, her clothes are
her plants, you know?
Didn't mean that in any other way.
Because, look, look, she's not wearing a red shirt here.
She's...
I'm saying it because she's wearing a red shirt.
She's not wearing a shirt here like her clothes are plants
and that's not a plant It's not like in any it's not
perverted way.
I'm not saying in a perverted way.
I'm saying it as a lore way That's not a part of her.
It's red.
That's not a natural plant I'm just saying it's not it
doesn't fit lore According to the lore My shirt should be
green.
Alan, on the feeling said what everyone wanted.
Shake my head.
They're all like little monkeys.
Who's they?
Okay.
A case of mistaken identity.
What?
Who?
Who is that?
Is that guard?
Wait, what are you?
Is Quincy?
Oh, Aaron?
You need to get me out of this cell.
It's me.
Cash.
I need it out there.
I can help you.
You've been, like, useless so far, though.
Why would I need your help?
Oh.
Harley?
You have to help me.
Ivy?
Gee, you look like crap.
Maybe I can seek you some shampoo.
Can't you hear them?
They're crying out to me in agony.
Yeah, well, I really don't have to come up to this Please
let me out.
They'll die without me.
I don't know red.
You're not a mr.
J's party list.
Oh, well Please The heck I'll cut your break
Why is she wearing a shirt?
No Evie I Told you to stay in there.
Ivy, what the fuck?
Whoa.
They're just really good friends, guys.
Guys, they're just best friends.
Ow.
No, I wanted to scat him.
Yeah, they're roommates.
No!
I wanted to scan him for Clayface!
Just gals being pals.
Alright, guess we'll rescue you.
He's taken control of the security overrides.
I have the sequence generator, but without the terminal in
my office, it's useless.
Your terminal has been destroyed.
Give me the sequencer.
What?
Oh, yes.
Of course.
It's like the Sailor Moon English dub where they're like,
they're just cousins.
Wow.
They're so, such good cousins to each other.
Bro can use five one two bit decryption key.
Use ultrasound to bypass security systems.
Oh my god, you finally do this.
There's always a way out.
always my fist will make the way out which one is it this
one okay yeah whoop i'll just shoot the problem oh never
mind what what what am i doing what the fuck am i doing
Is that hacking?
Is this...
Oh, I make it green.
Wait, oh, he changed.
Clayface.
I'm losing patience.
You're cheating.
Alright, initially an actor in horror films.
Kylo went mad when he learned a classic film of his was to
be remade with different actor in the lead role.
He took on the mask of the film's villain, Clayface.
and killed several of the remakes cast and crew before being
stopped by Batman and Robin.
Later, Carlo joined a mud pack in the lines of
shape-changing mutated villains who had subsequently used
the name Clayface.
While the group was defeated, Carlo tricked his allies and
injected himself with the essences of several of them.
Becoming a superhuman, imbued with the ability to change
shape, no, he just wants to be an actor.
That's all.
He doesn't want...
Oh, he must be, like, really old, too.
Because he was...
He got...
Oh,
yeah.
Any fun facts?
Six push five.
Professional criminal.
It can alter his physical form.
Adopting appearance of nearly anyone.
His mouthful.
His touch can be poisonous.
Get me out of here.
You rescued the wrong warden.
He's an imposter.
Wait, what is he doing with that doll?
Playface?
Clayface, what are you doing with this little doll?
I'm just curious, Clayface.
Whoa!
Again!
Is that it?
I don't think he knows Commissioner Gordon.
I don't think he knows like he I don't think he's like met
Commissioner Gordon he definitely hasn't really studied this
role yet again again again oh no more magic tricks no more
the Commissioner who laughs he probably only saw him on TV.
Yeah, he probably has.
He doesn't know, like, what he actually does.
Oh, riddle me this.
You...
Nice.
Riddle me this.
Fake fan.
Wait, if I talk to him, will he...
Will he change back?
No.
Aw, look, there's another wheelchair!
Like, I'm pretty sure there's not a lot of people who are,
like, who need that wheelchair.
I think it's just Joker trying to convince someone to do
stuff.
I don't want to break the glass.
What the fuck?
Who's your arm?
Is it inside?
I don't know what it is.
Who are you?
Oh, riddle me this.
can i hack this oh can i hack this i can
it's hacking time yay
are you okay sir intensive treatment extreme oh thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you in the morning i have
a competition later but watching a stream is more no you
have to win for me Han thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you you have to win for me go to sleep oh no
poison ivy's out alright where are the enemies enemy?
Wait really need this okay this is more important yay XP
what I have to do destroy the titan production facility and
botanical gardens.
Okay, I need to get to the botanical.
What the fuck is the botanical?
Okay, I have to go outside.
I have to go touch grass now.
Jesus Christ, get over here.
Alright, let's see.
Ooh.
Okay, I need to mark this.
One punch.
Like, I wish he did not have a single plan for this.
He did not have a fucking plan.
How do I do this?
Or just hack this?
Wait, can I hack this?
No.
Fuck.
Wait, how the fuck do I get over there?
It's so far!
What if I just...
Oh, lay there?
Okay, not yet.
Okay.
When you say later, it means I'm never coming back here.
Peter damn well never coming back
Bro how from how many people
Oh no Hey that just met I double dare you Oh shit Oh shit
where am I Oh, fuck!
Can't go back!
Oh, wait, I can't go up.
Nice.
God damn it!
Get up here.
It's not fair!
Oh, shit!
He's grabbing a gun!
Somebody stop him!
I'll stop him.
There you go.
Nice.
Yeah, just run away.
Alright, here's yeah.
Wait, there's more?
I'm sorry, if you all stay near me, it's like bowling again.
Just punch around on me!
Eventually!
Eventually it'll all hit you.
Okay.
I love buddy mashing.
It's my favorite part about fighting games.
Okay.
Am I?
Am I doing it?
Am I pressing Y and B?
Am I...
Nice.
Last guy.
Goodbye.
I'm doing it.
Was that as easy as it looked?
Well, it won't be so easy trying to catch me.
I mean, if I actually shoot you, it'd be...
easier i feel like why wouldn't i tranquilize your guns like
what are my batman gear that's just not just fist and bat
around i feel like it'd be easier to have a tranquilizer and
i can just tranquilize villains because i can't kill but i
can like put them to sleep if i put them in a coma does that
count as killing thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you it's 11 p.m i have nothing planned tomorrow but
doki stream is more important thanks for the e-friendly time
it's up to you and once thank you the super chat thank you
thank you it's no problem i want to do a longer stream today
for batman because i realized i am very behind in batman if
i put them in a vegetable state is that also killing this
rule sucks, Batman!
This roll fucking sucks!
Because, like, putting them in a vegetable state is almost
practically the same thing!
Oh, wait, let me hack this.
Yes!
Yeah, but technically I'm sort of doing it already!
I can't even think about it!
And then...
there you go this is if i was if i made this then it
wouldn't be hacking because i made it okay i'm a little lost
right now it is arguably worse like i'm practically oh yeah
me punching those henchments in the head is not technically
putting them in the vegetable state like
okay i'm making sure like everything i got it's locked what
i thought hacked everything let's do the hack
oh riddle's upper level well i already got that riddle
that's the gun you're just putting them in dream realm oh
there it is i didn't hack this wait what no i hacked that
i'm just gonna beat this guy up real fast monkey get over
here let me kill this guy first get over here nice rid of
you're standing in the way with my riddle all right here you
go no punch monkey didn't i hack everything What else do I
have to hack?
I hacked everything.
I'm just tucking...
Yeah, I'm just tucking them into bed.
Yeah, I hacked this.
Hack that.
Wait, there's something below me.
Oh, no, no, not that.
Hack the bodies.
This is not power, guys.
Can I hack this?
No.
What the fuck do I need to go?
The door is locked.
I'm chasing Harley.
Yeah, but the doors are locked.
I hacked everything.
I think?
I forgot where she ran to.
I flew up a wall?
I'm just like, when did I do that?
I'm so confused.
Where I got the last trophy.
I'm so lost.
This is why I need a robin.
Robins!
Where are you?
Go straight to the side.
This one?
Where are my robins?
Oh wait, this way.
That's me here.
Prometheus Arkham God's most wanted and most hated...
Wait, there's someone more hated than fucking Batman than
Batman and Joker?
No way.
Oh, let me do this.
Try using your...
No!
I'll need eyes when I have chat.
Who's my favorite, Robin?
What if I just let them die?
I didn't kill him.
Gravity killed him.
Oh, I have to save...
Why do I have to save them?
Oh, yeah, those two guards are the most important guards,
and I can just hire new ones.
Like, there's so many guards I've died already.
Like, at this point, it's just I don't really care anymore.
I just finally turned up.
Oh, yes.
Okay.
Okay, you do your exposition.
I'm going to do this.
Oh, it's not my fault.
Wait, what?
Wait, where's the other one?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, I don't do it.
Oh, they pressure!
That's okay.
No, it's not okay!
No!
I thought I could I thought I could do it I thought I could
just do it before it comes back up okay I'll let her do her
exposition I didn't think she was gonna turn it on again so
fast alright let her do her exposition this time
okay wow that's a nice toy you've got there
Oh, hacked.
No!
I don't like pressure!
Please.
Where can I get me one of those?
Please!
Don't try to back up!
I'm so stuck in the cutscene!
There you go.
Done
What How oh, oh, oh, I don't do well on
there hack the door Oh shit, oh shit.
Oh shit.
All right, 11 seconds I can do this Why do you have to take
so long to bring out your fucking hacking thing?
There you go Get out
oh i thought we were both gonna die in there you're safe now
nice going after that crazy witch i'm so good at this game
not even close and then her girlfriend and then the other
boyfriend and then the other boyfriend and then can i go
back inside now
Can I go back inside?
Oh wait, that's not the inside.
It was this way.
Is it locked forever?
No, it's locked forever!
Wait, where do I go?
This really... where do I go?
Just like, where?
Here?
Oh, there's a hack.
Must be a hack here too.
Alright, this way.
Oh.
It's not... Oh, there we go.
Yay!
This may take a while.
The systems lock me out.
Oh, shit.
This is the the gas chamber.
Wait, it was a real gas chamber this entire time.
Hey, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Okay.
Oh wait, I can go up.
Nice.
What do I do up here, though?
I can go up, but what's the point?
Really, let me do this!
Okay, I need to blow this up.
There you go.
Surely nothing bad's going to happen.
I'm underwear.
Yeah, see?
Oh, no, that's still the gas.
Wait, but where's the question?
question mark how do I do this no no it's so far I can't
turn the fan off come back later that's code for I'm never
coming back back tracking nah
Let's see.
I guess we go back here.
Room is the end of days for even the most celebrated killer.
What's that mean?
Bro, I'm on detective mode.
Can I get canceled for beating up?
For beating him up?
God damn it, Batman!
This is not good!
They need medical help!
Wait, who's that over there?
come on
oh no he's dead more teeth teeth teeth teeth is important i
guess here right
oh who has four walls two sides and one x dna i actually
don't know who that is all right who that did i already do
this i already did this hack.
I'll get over there so I can beat him up.
Is that Two-Face?
Oh, where Two-Face?
Security guard.
Oh, where do I get this out?
Wall.
Oh.
Wall Mountain and Heldwood.
Okay, I can't do that, obviously.
I'm so confused.
Look for his old cell.
Oh, dead!
There it is!
That's his cell.
District Attorney Harvey Dent was one of the Batman's
strongest allies in Gotham City.
Until the criminal threw acid in Dent's face, hitlessly
scarring him.
The wounds fractured his psyche and he was born as a
schizoid criminal mastermind, obsessed with duality.
His former good luck charm, a two-headed trick silver
dollar, was damaged on one side in attack, and Den has
seized on it as a reflection of his half-scarred visage.
On it as a reflection, he flips it to decide the fate of his
victims.
Despite Batman's effort to reform his former ally, Den is
consumed by his fixation on chance, and his crimes are
designated to design to prove out his diametric philosophy.
All right, how tall is he, though?
The most important question.
How tall is he?
He loosely scarred on the left side, which he plays out with
clothing, that's definitely solid on one.
It's not like, oh, I thought it was like a fun fact, but
it's just an attribute.
The question, how tall is he?
Where'd I go?
I'll always be lost.
I'll never, ever figure out where to go.
Let's stay here.
Clock gate.
Oh, my clock!
I've so many...
God, the Batman has so many gadgets.
I forgot.
Bro, I never used this.
Oh, my God.
His other...
His useful tool.
Wow!
Where did...
How did you get over here?
What the fuck?
Please.
don't cancel me he it was self-defense it's him again for
the record the patient has transferred
please take a seat guards you can leave us sorry doctor warn
you if you don't speak depressed does that help you can you
get into my mind doctor why bro he's depressed because he
can't kill one that got away
bro we will all want things all right it's part of growing
up sometimes you don't get what you want mofo thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you do you think batman sends
sends people to arkham asylum knowing that they look safe
just so he could be i think he has anger issues i think like
he just wants to beat up his problem instead of actually
rehabilitating like investing in like proper mental care to
these people like majority of the criminals here are just
like mentally unwell like i'm like there's literally like
six nurses like six nurses in the entire arkham asylum and
like i feel like you know maybe they have more nurses you
know maybe if arkham asylum a asylum a mental hospital
assigned more medical professionals things would be a little
better instead of six nurses
about it like that's the biggest issue i have on batman so
i'm like lagging by like crazy for some reason i'm like like
30 fps at the moment give me a sec i'm like 30 fps for some
fucking reason oh my god i don't know why i'm give me a sec
let me set this six nurses electrical bill of one million
let's see whoa why am i lagging so badly maybe if i okay let
me reset this real fast like there's a lot of like issues
with gotham gotham in general just has is not really the
perfect city but yet like for some reason gotham has like so
many billionaires maybe gotham is like texas in a way that
like taxes are like um the tax it's like it's like the taxes
are really like barely existent in in gotham so like all the
billionaires live all the billionaires live there.
I think like maybe like the servers are like actual I'm like
semi it's alright we're just gonna go retro like I'm saying
it's like Texas and more so like the tax there's like barely
taxes in general so then like that's why all the
billionaires live in Texas not Texas are billionaires live
in Gotham all right what do we upgrade
uh there's batteram power twin batteram sonic batteram
multiple
sonic batteram what does a sonic batteram do okay what does
it do i swear to god you're making me upgrade a dumb tune
the resonant exact frequency nearest attracting the useful
for luring a target into a trap or away from an area one
throw requires a short recharge peripheral for it can be
used oh it lures them why would i need to lure them i can
just beat them up i guess i can use the i don't have any
traps though all right we'll do it fine fine i'll do it all
right is this another rock oh up scum thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you $100 nurses, $30 meds, $10
restraints, $5 billion on bat-themed combat year.
Doki, who's going to become good at payroll?
Please help me.
My family keeps losing.
Boy, assassin.
I mean, Batman is willing to just throw away, like, his
fucking car so easily.
And that car is, like, I would not be surprised if it's,
like, $100 million.
I would not be surprised at a hundred million dollar car
right there.
He doesn't care!
Hey, we're gonna need this.
Stop buying bat team...
No.
They're not even great gadgets, too.
Oh, yeah.
I didn't see the hack here.
Yeah.
I hate the argument of, like, how much prep time does Batman
have would be like, who's going to win?
Batman versus X, and then people would be like, how much
prep time does he get?
Well, sometimes people don't get prep time.
Majority of time, people will never get prep time if you
think about it.
Usually, when something happens, it sometimes comes by a
surprise.
Why are we giving him prep time?
...
A good villain would never give you prep time.
It's always a surprise.
Excellent.
I'll leave it to you then, my dear.
Get him!
Where?
Oh, there.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Let me beat up some people real quick.
Ooh, nice.
That's fucking right.
Get down.
Oh, shit!
Electricity!
Oh!
My floor is lava!
Floor is lava!
Alright, get over here.
It's fine.
We're fine here.
It's not this floor.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, where the fuck...
Oh!
please that's so long get me out of here
oh my god that's so scary that's so fucking scary
no no no no no get me out get me out get me out nice that's
right you can't fuck with me harley like how they're just
waiting there it's like harley can we play now can we even
the goons are like move i like how they're like can we come
play now with mr batman
is it time now oh i thought i got them don't let him just
don't get hit oh get out oh shit oh shit there you go i need
to like oh no why are you letting yourself get hit then oh
shit give me up give me up oh i hate that i'm so bad at this
one okay there you go nice that should be the last nope
that's not the last guy okay all right we need the regen we
need the regen guys no no no no No, it's electricity guy!
It's okay.
I have a plan.
Okay, it was not this.
He can just kick me like that!
Okay, I got a plan, guys.
I got a plan.
There we go.
I got a plan if I keep running back and forth I gotta whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
okay okay we're fine no no oh god we're fine we're fine why
are you in a dream i should have given him more prep time
but i tried my best sorry but there is no prize for second
place i'm afraid to rob the party What the fuck?
You're just gonna do that to party like that?
No!
It's okay, she has Ivy.
Her best friend and roommate.
We've been easy with prep time.
Wait, who's that?
Why the smiles next to certain names?
Yeah.
You're the detective, you tell me.
backseat me, Harley.
Just punch her in the head like all the other ones.
What?
You won't hit a woman?
She killed more people than the Joker goons.
He's in the secret lab in the gardens and, oh crap.
Yep, I know.
She literally killed more than the other guys.
What the fuck?
This should be equality!
Oracle, I'm done.
Harley is...
Oh, she's quiet.
So you can find the secret lab in the gardens.
Yes.
Harley's been everywhere on the island.
So I'm calibrating the scanner to only show prints that have
traces of chlorophyll.
Okay, listen.
Be careful.
I rerouted away.
I can fix her, but she's high.
...
guys i don't think she's fixable guys i don't think i'm
gonna use the bathroom i'll be right back
all right i'm back can you guys still fix her
I can fix it with enough prep.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
All I'm saying is that I'm okay with giving these guys
fucking concussions But like Harley who has killed so many
people in two hours.
I just put her in the fucking cell I like I just put her in
the fucking prison cell like what is this check the ice cell
there's an ice cell there's more than one
boy there's so many shit going on I beat up so many people
holy fuck oh there it is oh there you go there you go I see
it Mr. Freeze Victor Fry's was a brilliant crowd genesis
whose beloved wife Nora was tricky with a fatal degenerative
disease he placed her in suspended animation whilst
obsessively um searching for a way to cure her the
corporation that funded his research and norah's life pulled
the plug triggering an accident that transformed fry's body
into a uh into a cold blooded form that must always be kept
below zero at normal room temperature he will die willing a
number of freezing weapons he wears protective armor and his
quest to somehow bring back his lovely wife and avenge her
fate which he partly holds the batman responsible for what
the fuck did batman do was he the one that like pulled the
funding marcus thank you for the future uh thank you for the
future chat super chat thank you thank you i can fix it just
trust the process oh yeah what are the fun facts how tall
what is the most empowering fact how tall is the six feet
all right professional specialty employers extent Wait,
what?
What about his wife?
What's that about his wife?
Motivized grief and anger.
Oh, shit, by spite, just like me.
For real, for real.
Let's see.
Oh, nice.
We're... Jesus Christ, that's a lot of bodies.
That's...
Ice to meet you.
Thank you for the super chapter, Maynator.
Thank you.
Alright.
Is there anything over here?
Oh, wait, this should be.
Yeah, there should be a video.
What is he
saying?
Oh, shit!
How the fuck is he stronger than the guard?
I would assume the guards are more trained than him.
He's literally in asylum.
There's no way.
There's no way he's getting the proteins necessary to keep
up his muscle.
Poor bitch.
Poor me.
Hiring these god-awful guards.
Alright, hacking time.
Wait, what?
Can I hack?
Currently inactive.
Oh, they're all inactive.
Oh, wait, no.
Except for this one.
I guess it's sort of like prison.
I mean, it is prison where they like train up.
All they do is fucking it.
All they do is fucking get buffed as fuck in prison and
lifting weights and stuff.
I feel like If yours are I feel like if I was like the
warden of Arkham Asylum I would not buy any train Like I
would not buy a gym Like why the fuck would I give prisoners
time to train and get buff
No I'm so stow wow Never mind I got trapped by ridders this
is why you should not be a completionist
nice they brought the animal before me shameless and barking
like a mad dog for what felt like days i endured his boasts
he took pleasure recounting his actions cataloging his
depraved crimes what should have been revenge turned to pity
this poor dog needed my help oh wait how do i get up oh wait
there wrapper nice okay now now i go i missed calendar man
said man's cell god there's so many fucking bodies but all
i'm saying is that i would never have like i would never
like have a gym at for my prison because i do not want them
to get buff
like what what's the point why am i training them to be like
better people like why am i training them to be buff people
to kill again like i think that's stupid Where do I go?
Track Harley's fingerprints.
Where?
Where is her fingerprints?
Do I?
Do I go back?
Oh, wait, is that door?
That's a door!
Wait, no.
No, wait.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Do I go backwards?
I must go backwards.
There's nowhere else to go.
What did you touch, Harley?
Oh, yeah, it's backwards.
It's backwards.
Okay, that Arkhamad.
Okay, I got it.
I figured it out.
It's up here.
We're always lost.
That's my secret, Chad.
Alright, this way.
This way.
Oh.
God, I was not- I did not realize that was a gift.
I guess you don't have to pay them, too.
Because they'll be too stupid to want money.
If you, like, expose them to the chemicals.
smart.
What do you think about?
There's so many riddles.
I'm just going to pretend I didn't see it.
Oh!
That's, this is Calendar Man still.
Where's Calendar Man?
Look at that.
See guys?
I'm not that stupid.
I recognize this riddle for Calendar Man.
Okay.
No, Joker apparently pays really well because he doesn't do
shit for money.
Like, he does this for, like, he doesn't care about money so
he actually pays really really well because he doesn't care
about the money that he gets from the heist all he does he
cares about is mayhem so he gives away all the money uh to
his yeah it's about the message so he pays he's actually a
really nice boss when it comes to the money not the other
stuff though
like oh there it is this has to hey guys where you guys
think is calendars man sell do you think it's the one filter
of calendars uh
calendar man god that outfit is so stupid fixated on the
calendar julian day became calendar man a villain who tied
and tied his crimes met thematically to certain holidays
throughout the year often leaving clues by which he could be
caught.
Gotham City's hopes for a day off are often clouded by a
knowledge that any holiday of note is likely to be shadowed
by calendar man's presence.
Then like, don't release him on holidays.
On holidays, you put him on house arrest.
Because he has a pattern.
Gotham!
Just put him on house arrest on holidays!
Don't have a holiday in Goth...
You know what?
Just don't have a holiday in Gotham City.
He escapes, obviously.
Well, cap him on 24 hours.
There's not enough holidays in the world.
Guys, there's...
First off, there's not a lot of holidays.
So you can use one day on...
You can use the holidays to...
To fucking...
Make sure he doesn't escape.
Is he getting away with...
Just go somewhere else.
Clearly his only crime is in Gotham City.
So have a vacation outside of Gotham.
What about birthdays?
Okay, I don't think Calendar Man gives a fuck about
birthdays, guys.
That's not a holiday.
Your boss is not going to give you a holiday because it's
your birthday.
Don't fucking...
Guys.
Guys, you go to work on your birthday.
Welcome to adult life.
I'm sorry.
You're fucking working on your holiday, guys.
Stop talking.
That is definitely news.
We don't have proof, but he's definitely dead.
I like how someone was like, But Doki, my birthday is on
summer break.
I hate to break it to you, but like, For some jobs, there's
no summer break.
In the adult world.
Okay, let's see.
We have to go this way.
No, don't tell it.
No, don't tell him that.
No!
Please, I'm trying to talk to my chat, sir.
why would you tell him that wait is he stuck oh i thought he
was like stuck in the fucking stuck in the wall wait can i
open this oh shit i can wait open oh i can be here too i can
be just like you sir no santa is real don't worry at least
that's one thing we can count on uh santa's a mutant in the
x-men this is a wrap thank you the super chat thank you
thank you jokie's a pretty good boss until he's not.
Give me a consistent crook.
Oh, so like, you know, Radar, like, I don't care about these
guys now being out.
Because they're, like, weaker than the other goons.
Oh, do you think there's...
Wait.
This should be...
Did I unlock more in the Easter egg time?
Let me check.
Madison, thank you for the super chat think you think oh he
has a different pose now he's so quirky let's talk about
employee relations bats harley disappointed me and now she's
out of the picture gone forgotten dead to me you get the
idea what's it like in your organization do you punish your
hired help when they fail you or is that saucy outfit you
make him wear punishment enough which one Well, there's a
reason why I have, like, 500 robins.
I'm done playing with you right now.
Time for a new robin.
Alright, let's see.
These guys are so fucking weak, like, I just slap him once.
Like, I'm just like, am I supposed to be scared of these
guys?
Or am I gonna have, like, the regular Joker goons?
The regular ones are at least more of a challenge.
These guys are just it's just sad Oh, wait Wait, what?
Oh shit, what the fuck is going on?
Oh, it's the side
How did they beat up the guys with guns?
They're literally one-shot!
How did you die?
They're so weak
Help!
I'm too strong.
They have guns!
Okay, it's this way.
Wow.
Oh my, this is sad.
I'm- This is so sad.
Please stop.
This is too sad.
Dogs are supposed to get harder, not easier.
Come on.
What- Joker, you fucking fell off.
Like, the fact that it just takes one hit.
That's the saddest part.
What's the riddle?
I already forgot the riddle.
It's the free XP.
Thank you for the free XP.
What the fuck is the ridder?
Batman is too strong.
Wait, deceased?
Oh no, he's okay.
These guys are deceased.
In the graveyard?
Oh, it's on the other side.
Okay.
I thought like it was like, uh...
Okay, I thought it was like in that little hole.
that we're in.
All right, come over here.
Teeth!
There you go.
All right, we're gonna go to the gardens!
Poison Ivy!
I'm coming over!
Teeth!
Is the number up to the guards?
Oh, not botanical time?
Oh, no, it is a botanical tab.
Okay, locate.
Tracker thing.
Oh, there's your finger.
Wait, did she touch the floor?
Why the fuck did you touch the floor?
Oh, maybe she's, like, doing cartwheels, you know?
Maybe.
Wait, are they dead?
Oh, I was like, oh, how nice they're reading books.
Why is she touching so many floors?
Okay.
Oh, watch this.
Wait,
wait.
Watch this.
Come on.
It worked!
It's one!
One is something!
What is something?
It's that easy.
Nice.
It's the number of...
You may still reach a level just below my genius one day.
What the fuck?
What did you say?
Scrub.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Please put me in a vegetable state so poison ivy will love
me.
Okay.
That's pretty good.
Poison Ivy will never love you.
Alright.
What do we upgrade, guys?
What's the best upgrade to get?
I missed the tape.
Where's the tape?
Oh, tape on the bench?
Okay.
You have to face reality right now!
She's never gonna love you!
You're not a pig.
Even if you're a vegetable state, you don't have any greens
in you.
Your twin batteran?
Okay, I'm gonna get the twin batteram.
Combo batteram?
What the fuck is combo batteram?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I'll do that.
If I want to plant, mommy, fucking date a florist.
It's less lethal.
There's no fucking...
There's no tape here.
Oh, there's tape here.
It's not the same.
Today is a special day.
This is the anniversary of...
He showed me the bigger world.
You tried to kill everyone in Gotham.
Well, sometimes you need to broom back hard in order to make
something flourish.
To be fair, if she was a real eco-terrorist, she would not
be aiming for Gotham City.
Because she could just aim for the oil rigs in the ocean.
That's like owned by the entire, like by private
corporations.
That's not in Gotham City.
Not a real eco-terrorist.
Fucking rookie.
but she's just a rookie you gotta start small if she wants
to change the world she should not be aiming for small poser
what a fucking poser
okay where the fuck there you go
she's like those fucking there's like those ones that like
threw paint on the Mona Lisa oh wait I almost ran this way
because like they're just trying to like get more because
like the whole idea is that um any publicity is good
publicity so like do they have guns oh they do that's scary
oh that's a lot of them or sorry soup they threw soup at the
Mona Lisa because their idea is that any publicity is good
publicity.
So they're like, weirr.
Oops.
I fucked up!
Ah, shit!
Fly, fly, fly!
It's okay.
They always forget.
But like, it doesn't really work like that.
Wait, there's...
Pulling!
sure it came from over there okay wait i can blow it again
don't worry i can blow it again wait they had their guns
again no my bully
i almost got a strike I almost got a strike guys.
It was so close.
No, you guys.
No, no, no, no.
It was all.
I almost got a strike, guys.
I almost did it.
You don't understand.
There you go.
That's different.
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Let me punch you.
There you go.
Alright, it's fine.
fine.
How do I activate?
Okay, I don't have double batter hands yet.
No!
Like he's left you a gift up there!
Cute, cute!
Oh, yes!
No!
How did he get him so fast?
I don't understand!
No!
Joker, you ghoster!
Joker's ghosting!
Also isolated, thank you for attending, bitches!
Thank you!
I can't believe he's a ghoster!
Fucking no integrity!
I can't believe my criminal doesn't have any integrity.
It's so fucked up.
I'm just gonna...
Nothing?
That's so fucked up.
No.
Okay.
No, you did it.
Get up.
There you go.
This is my stealth.
This is my stealth, guys.
There you go.
No.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
They can't see me.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
I told you I don't need stealth!
boom apparently i can cut them down too guys i learned
something new i can cut him out okay all right if all right
him falling on his head is not a bad thing okay how do i get
this guy get over here come on come over here it's not oh
where where is he is he like in front of me like where is he
whoop see i told you guys i can do this bam
hell yeah first try first
fucking try let's go all right it's here um can i open the
door now am i missing anything here whoops oh reload me this
is this a reload me this
but anyway as i was saying i never understood the i never
understood that they like do publicity stunts to like get
attention regarding like ecological ecological uh ecological
like awareness because it's like it just makes you look
stupid like yes you're getting attention but like you're
just making people more spiteful and like they're gonna be
like you don't have fuck to you know like it's just gonna
make people who be like fuck the environment like even if
you were trying to convince them to like care about the
environment people are just gonna be like no fuck the
environment remember the wings how could anyone forget oh it
just ends up making people like hate you more oh hey
remember Thomas Wayne and Martha Wayne nice look at that I
can solve for this no dokey that's just you no it's not I
don't I like I'm not gonna be fuck the environment but it
makes people want to be like fuck the environment because
people would be like you're that's so stupid uh Thomas Wayne
was a gifted surgeon an heir to the Wayne fortune dedicated
to philanthropy as much as medicine he and his wife Martha
were well known and respected in Gotham Martha Wayne shared
her shared her husband Thomas charitable nature and was
dedicated to her son's Bruce upbringing she was well
dedicated to her son oh wait she was well regarded in the
Gotham city's social circles and helped host lavish charity
bars at Wayne Manor their tragic murder at the hands of the
desperate burglar Joe Chill In Gotham's crime, Ali shook the
city to its core and led to years of urban blight.
It also inspired their son, Bruce, to eventually become the
Batman.
Oh, wait.
Fun facts.
I forgot about what are the heights.
6'1 and 5'8".
Man, even she's taller than the penguin.
Wait, she's so tall.
5'8?
Does that count the heels?
You're so fucking tall.
Howly gifted and well-trained surgeon.
Air to the wing.
Dedicated mother to Bruce Wayne.
Wife to talk.
I like how like the attributes is like she's a mom.
She's a wife.
Mixed fun of crime alley when she goes to RS alley.
Thank you, the super chat.
Dr. Crammer.
Thank you.
Is there anything here?
Oh, wait.
Teeth.
nice i got the teeth i know we're supposed to go here but
maybe there's like bonus things here so i want to make sure
there's whoa whoa i can't help you you're lucky the boss
don't want you hurt too bad said something about you being
the perfect bait don't get it you're nothing special who's
gonna save you yeah and just in case someone does decide to
try we're ready and wait but bad man I'm still.
Just rough him up a little bit.
Teach him a lesson.
Yeah, boys.
Wait, this is a perfect!
This is a perfect bullying!
This is perfect bullying!
Okay.
Okay, I can get a strike here.
It's perfect!
Wait, he got him so fast!
What the fuck?
That's bullshit!
Why did he get to get him so fast?
This is bullshit.
Not gonna lie.
Bro, that's no not fair.
That's not fair.
Alright, nice.
Get up What the fuck you get to stop a takedown?
That should be illegal You okay I was like, wait bro are you
okay?
Sorry about that I didn't mean to
Nice, okay nice That's a lot of XP too They're dead Oh wait,
what the fuck?
I was like, I was like, they're dead.
Turns around the corner.
Sure.
Carl Todd.
Who are you?
You're a janitor?
Oh, you are.
I'm fine.
I eat punks like these for breakfast.
What were they doing in here?
The ones that weren't hitting me went over there and started
doing something to the power controls.
I have no idea what they were doing.
Karatad next to the the crowbar looks like Joker is booby
trapped as control box this is going to be tougher than
before but it's a risk I'll need to take that's gonna happen
it's gonna explode oh my god it's so difficult the hot what
wait there's more than one there yeah oh there's three
that's why that makes sense There you go.
Easy.
Nice.
I did it.
I thought the gardens would be the last place those escaped
goons would be interested in.
So much for logic in this place.
Maybe just leave.
Actually, no, they can't leave because it's an island.
I was wondering, where are the boats?
Sorry, he can't just leave.
Yeah, but like, poison ivy.
Why would you think it's the last place people will leave?
B.
It's literally poisonous.
What the fuck?
What are all these?
Are these things at the bottom?
Oh, it's the booby traps.
Okay.
What do I do?
Wait, can't you swim?
Yeah.
Yeah, couldn't you swim?
Couldn't this guy fucking swim?
There's no sharks in fucking got... Actually, there might
be.
Because there's like what's his name king shark never mind
there could be sharks because there's king sharks i forgot
in gothams jesus christ in gothams city
all right i'm just gonna i'm sorry joker
you were a doctor she's still a doctor she doesn't lose her
doctorate
she's had platinum but doesn't mean she didn't go to college
what do you mean she was a doctor did she lose her license
oh she could have lost her license
i forgot that can happen i forgot that can happen
i forgot they could possibly revoked her phd uh from from
killing people you're right You're right.
All right, I'm this one in the next room.
I can't believe it.
She lost her license.
I can't believe murder can make you lose your license.
It's a bit unfair.
You're right.
You can't revoke a PhD.
I get so lonely on my own.
Oh.
Just don't let me know.
Steven.
You beta He has a wife What's wrong with you You sip Call me
Ivy Of course I love you Oh my god Home wrecker Oh yeah how
could she lose her fucking PhD She's still a doctor She's
still a doctor Ivy Oh, these doctors have that.
I can fix some attitude.
Barley, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're all Steven's cater.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You guys won't leave me for Ivy, right?
Wow, Mad Hatter.
Okay, which one's the Mad Hatter?
Oh, there it is.
Is that the Mad Hatter?
No, that's not.
I'm at it guys.
I'm serious guys.
What does Ivy have that I can provide?
I can provide entertainment
Would she play Batman Arkham Asylum?
What's my p?
Okay, look.
She can't even practice her fucking doctorate.
Her PhD is useless.
Also, where the fuck is mad hatter puzzle she can't just not
legally oh
so now she's not she was never a real doctor anyway it's a
PhD it's not even a medical doctor it's just professors it's
just a it's just a PhD professor he she writes research
papers not fucking not fucking cures cancer
okay but like you know oh there it is but like i'm not
trying to say professors do not deserve to be called doctors
i just want you guys to know that you know
i'm just saying that like you guys are saying she's a
medical doctor but she is not a medical doctor she is a
theoretical doctor i several people are typing a young age
with lewis caro's book of alice adventures in wonderland
jarvis is uh jarvis jarvis jervis tech and expert hypnotist
embraced the delusion that he was the incarnation of a
character in the story the mad hatter using his skills for
mesmerism the mad hatter has committed many crimes often
themed around the book that inspired him and his love of
hats and headgear oh my god he plays Team Fortress 2.
Doing so far as to implant his hats with mind-controlled
chips to amplify the synopsis skills.
Above all other headwear, however, he covets Batman's
distinctive cal and will stop at just fucking hiring a
cosplayer!
Make it...
Oh yeah, it's a collector's item.
Oh, he wants especially one of a kind items.
All right, where do I go?
It's this way.
He wants the real thing.
He wants the one of a kind color.
Okay, but like Batman does not have one bat suit.
That's all I'm going to say.
There's no way he has one bat suit.
Just give him the cow to stop so he stop.
He's also schizophrenic.
They're all schizophrenic!
there's a pattern Batman oh shit at this rate you'll never
catch me Batman if the majority of the villain is
schizophrenic maybe the issue is the schizophrenia that's
running around fucking Gotham City he's also schizophrenic I
swear 80% of these villains are just schizophrenic Look!
Delusion schizophrenic!
There must be something... You know, it might be the water,
honestly.
I feel like there's something wrong with the gene pool in
Gotham City.
Like, it's like Australia where like all the criminals got
like...
got like deported to Australia a long time ago.
Like, I feel like at this point there's... there's has to be
a pattern.
Like, there's something has to be in the water!
Or, like, medical history, there's something wrong!
Batman!
Please, fund the medical facilities in Gotham City, Batman!
That's all we need!
We can fix it so easily.
It's always the water.
Oh, no.
Oh, hey.
Reload me this.
Oh, no.
Why is there mushrooms here?
Oh.
Here we go.
Nice.
Can't believe you blame my felonies on my genetics.
It's like the murder cheese.
Whoops, sorry.
It's like the murder cheese from Riverdale.
I make sure there's...
Oh, it's so nice that the mod gets rid of the flashbang.
It's actually so fucking nice, man.
Holy shit.
The shadows can only be seen by those with a different view
of life.
What the fuck does that mean?
What?
What the fuck is that?
Joker?
Ooh.
I don't like this.
Joker.
What the fuck do I get out of here?
Oh, this way.
Wee!
I missed the scan in the vent.
It's alright.
I cannot deal with mazes.
A rat catcher needs more than just his charm to lead.
Oh, it's the Pied Piper.
I need to scan some rats.
Where are the rats?
Whoop.
What the fuck is that?
Oh.
I told you what you wanted to know.
Pulling time.
You can let me go.
Hey, you promise you won't tell anyone about Joker's plan?
Well, okay then.
Help this guy to his feet.
Then shoot him in the face.
Why do we always go back to Riverdale, Toki?
Alan, thank you, thank you.
You think we just let you walk out of here?
Doesn't even have guns.
How do they shoot?
It's funny.
Listen up.
I'm going to kick you a bit more.
Then when you pass out, I drag you back in there and throw
you down the hall.
Let all your friends watch.
Yeah.
I could stop this at...
Oh!
I could have stopped this at any time, but I had to stay
there for a long.
How fucked up are you, Doki?
I'm sorry.
I saved you earlier, but the lore was more important!
God damn, I hated when they interrupted my fucking
finishers.
I'm so sorry, man, the lore was just too good.
Alright, are you okay?
Sorry for giving you extra trauma.
Are you okay?
Do I look okay?
They were gonna kill me.
Yeah, I just got there, sorry.
I literally just got there.
Are they still in there?
No, man.
No one's come out since.
You've got to help them.
Stay here.
I was not watching.
I swear to God.
Rescue orderlies held hostage in the Avery.
In the Avery.
Where am I?
There's so many objectives.
Oh my god.
There's so many things to do.
Can't you do this?
Okay.
Oh, hey, really need this.
Oh, I don't have that thing again.
Is it this way?
Yeah, that should be it.
Where are the fucking rats?
She's using her womanly charms against him.
Ducky, thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Clearly, those grunts don't know the epic guy in Lowe's of
high school.
I fucking love that quote.
Is this a tribute to...
Oh, wait, Constantine?
Oh, Constance.
Okay, never mind.
There's no claws in the guard so someone's using the roof
instead.
Is that one of the orderlies?
Wait, how did they get them in there?
The bat is on the way.
If you see him, send the annoying doctors to hell.
Yeah, they're going down.
Oh.
If I hear what?
If I hear what, Joker!
What am I going to hear?
Joker!
If I hear what?
I'll never know.
I'll never know, guys.
Oh my god, I was too slow.
I'll never know what I'm gonna hear.
My god.
I can't believe it.
That was too slow.
Please.
Did it crash again?
Like, what?
Oh my god, it crashed again.
No!
Give me a second, crash it again.
Let me...
Yeah.
Play.
Next time, man.
Do be fair.
Like, this PC has been like...
It's just been like Frankenstein.
For us.
So maybe there has always been that one part that's fucking
up my PC, but I'll never know.
Okay.
Played it recently, mod 3 and still crashes.
It's not me!
It's just that...
Okay, games that are like...
Old games are not compatible with new stuff, to be fair.
Because, like, you know...
Like, they're not compatible in terms of, like, the more new
it is.
Like, the graphics cards are not compatible with the old
shit in games.
Alright, y'all finally...
I finally know!
Get me out of this thing!
Listen, the Batman's on the way.
If you see him, send the annoying doctors to happen.
Yeah, the optimization.
That's the down one, right?
Yeah.
They're going down.
Joker's men are all wearing the security colors.
I'll need to take out the operator first.
No, is this stealth?
No.
Is this stealth?
No!
Okay, okay, I have the Sonic Battle Ram.
There you go.
Look over.
What?
No!
It could be anybody's Battle Ram!
It could be anybody's!
Why would it be me?
Guys, it could be anybody!
I don't understand.
How did he know?
It could be Robbins.
Like, how did he know it's mine?
I don't understand.
It literally could have been anybody's.
That's all I'm going to say.
Who else?
I don't know.
Other bat enthusiast.
Why did Junker crash the game?
Is he stupid?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It could have been a Batman fan, you know?
Okay, all right.
It's capitalism.
Someone, they must have sold, like, bootleg Batman Battle
Rams.
All right?
Like, someone has merchandise, Batman.
I bet you, Bruce, I bet you Bruce Wayne has, like, trademark
Batman.
There's no fucking way Battle Ramps are not like a trademark
item where people fucking sell it.
There's no fucking way.
No.
Joker wants some style.
I'm gonna do it.
I don't know how that works, but okay.
Yes, but no.
There's no fucking way.
He does not have Batman trademarked.
Pretend that's the same metal Kate, right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There has to be Batman merch.
It's fucking capitalism.
Why would they not fucking capitalize on Batman?
I bet you Batman is somebody's Oshi.
Hey, how the fuck do I do this?
Batman better not try and mess with us not kill him
Okay No No I can't believe it I'm so close How Oh my god,
how I'm so fucking sad.
I'm so sad.
I was doing so well.
He saw my hands.
I don't understand.
Kaz, Bruce Wayne having Batman trademark will be a little
bit sussy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's why he has so many robins!
Exactly!
Limited edition new robin merch!
Oh my god.
Bro, it makes so much more sense.
I am cast.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It makes sense.
Stop it.
New Robin debut.
Oh my god.
Robin debut.
Help me.
Someone.
Get me out of this thing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Jason was not making it.
enough money so they had to they had to graduate him but
then it was a publicity stunt so it boosted Jason's number
it boosted Jason's number by grad by and then like they
brought him back they ungraduated him it's
so smart Bruce is so fucking smart oh my god this is how he
became a billionaire this is exactly how merchandising
merchandising Batman merchandising is the most lucrative
like It's the most lucrative way to earn money from him Wait
scan the guy on the wall There's a guy
Yeah but tech is like a side thing It's the side gear Oh
this guy
Killer that's the killer mod
Walker was a minor criminal who adopted the identity of
Cameron Van Cleer, a bastard criminal who in turn
masqueraded as a costume super villain, killer moth.
He has a hired gun for Gotham's Oh my god.
It looks fucking stupid.
But his, and he used a weapon including his Cancun gun, does
not protect him from regular defeat at the hands of Batman.
We don't fuck would hire this guy.
With the fame and identity chance, skilled inventor.
Immoral and way of my feelings of insecurity.
Oh I'm sorry, I didn't mean that.
I'm sorry, man.
I didn't mean that.
I'm sorry, bro.
I was...
No, no, please.
I don't want to fuck it up again.
Okay, I can do this.
I can do this, guys.
You matter, Mothman.
You matter.
Why did I say that?
Fucking who told me to do the takedown?
Alright.
I listened to the one guy that was like you should do the
takedown.
And I was like I should do the takedown.
God damn it.
I got one guy.
It was me.
Fuck you.
I saw someone that was like do the silent takedown.
It'll be so funny.
I was like, whoa, really?
Would it actually be that funny?
Alright.
How the fuck?
Please get me out of here.
Please.
It was me, Barry.
God, just let these janitors die!
I don't care anymore.
Bab, I should get two.
She should get at least two.
All I'm saying is that I should get at least two.
Okay, I'm gonna run.
Alright.
Wait, do I have to scan it again?
Do I have to scan this fucker again?
I'll scan him later when I kill them all.
I'm gonna do that little thing I did earlier.
It doesn't stand a chance.
Not a chance.
There you go.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
Take down the head henchmen.
What?
Take down?
Oh, I did it.
I did it.
Now pull the lever.
You're right.
Push try.
Okay.
Now I can scan him.
Wait, but is that what they want?
They get to be strong.
Oh, hey.
Hey there.
I didn't even see you.
Alright, where's the...
Where's he?
Let me scan him again.
Let me scan him first.
Don't come over!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Get over here.
Oh, wait.
That's the last guy.
Oh, fuck.
Nice.
I did it.
Rob, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I feel like Jason graduated from being big hit on the
Indies.
By the way, I'm loving the stream, Jokey, keep it.
Yeah, but he crawled back to Batman.
Joker wanted the entrance to the Titan production plant
guarded.
I should pick up Harley's trail again so I can find it.
Alright, cut over here.
I saved your life, we're gonna say.
Say thank you!
I'm sorry.
I thought I was working for Dr. Young.
I had no idea Joker was involved until he burst in the lab.
Where is the lab?
Back over there.
I always get buzzed through.
There's a hidden door, but, well, you know, it's hidden.
I'll find it.
Stay here.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, yes!
He does have a wife!
He does have a wife.
Other robins eventually come back.
The merchandising is just too good.
The branding.
It's almost like Nightwing.
Nightwing had a good...
Nightwing becomes Batman later.
He's part of the problem.
He doesn't have his solo career because he ends up becoming
Batman.
It's all connected.
Where'd I go?
Did I go the other way?
Oh yeah, I guess so.
Right at the other door, right?
Batman's just too good of a branding!
The capitalism!
It's just too good!
Just think about the merchandising!
Is it in Termina?
Oh, don't leave?
Okay, don't save.
that pump my oh she
there's a hidden terminal where oh there it is I see it
please please no no no no no no no no no I'm good sorry I
sort of ran sorry
the wall there's a vent over there How do I get to that
vent?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I can open it.
I was going to say I should use my backlaw or not.
I bet you Superman isn't even a farmish boy.
It's just all PR.
I bet you Clark Kent isn't a farm boy.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, no.
Don't say that.
Wait,
what?
I'm just back here.
Wait, I could have done that.
I could have just done this?
Wait, this is what...
This was naturally, no.
This was more complicated.
It was actually more complicated.
Not gonna lie.
What the fuck is this statue?
follow the fingerprints okay let me find the fingerprints
that was the intended way I made it much more difficult I
ran past the secret tunnel look I fucking gained so hard
like come on what I did was cooler I'm not gonna lie I
could went up my god I could went so many different other
ways Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Time to do the Joker gas.
Yay!
There we go.
Where's that?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, thank God it's next to me because I would never find it.
Thank fucking God.
Joker!
secret lab since you've made it this far let me show you
what I cooked up
he's gonna do it they're gonna go bane he's beating out
never go full bane oh oh god I like
how his their pants are okay
Wow!
What the fuck?
I cannot charge that!
Okay, that's bullshit.
That is so bullshit.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
What is he doing?
Ow.
That is okay.
That is actually bullshit.
Bullshit, though.
Alright, here we go.
There's two.
How the fuck?
No!
This is much worse!
Okay, there you go.
I can hit both of them at the same time.
That's fucking right.
No!
He's in...
I need to get this guy, too!
What do I do?
Oh, I just didn't hit him.
Okay.
I'm just like, what do I do?
Get him, too.
That's right.
Stop hitting yourself.
Are you guys stupid?
Oh, shit.
I didn't mean that.
I'm so sorry.
I did not mean that.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
They're picking up people.
Okay, I need a gift.
Get out of there.
Oh, okay.
Get on.
Piggy back time.
It's piggy back time.
Get over here.
We got hit each other.
It's the only way.
Tossing people.
That's illegal.
Why are they tossing people?
Why can't I toss people?
I should be strong enough.
You guys Totally I like how he can hit his teammate too
That's actually pretty funny Charge me But You're too far
can you get closer You're too far Nice
Alright Charge, charge, charge, charge Nice Wait did he Is
he gonna die now?
Okay.
Almost there.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, nice.
I dodged.
Fucking dodged.
Nice.
Okay.
One down.
Wait, can I just, like, poke him and he'll die?
Oh, nice.
Yeah, I can.
Okay.
Please.
Please let me pick you up!
You wouldn't let me pick him up.
Easy.
Oracle.
I've destroyed the Titan production facility.
But Joker escaped with enough to cause us real problems.
Just when you think it can't get any worse.
They've been using a venom plant hybrid to create the Titan
strain.
One person on Arkham Island who can help us and what makes
you think poison ivy will help you if her plants are at risk
She'll listen.
I have a sample of her plant life matters She'll be
somewhere in the gardens.
I'll track her down All right, let's go this way no way out
this elevator shaft mutual coming up It's time it's time
it's time for that one oh wait upgrade time
Upgrade time.
Which, what upgrade do we get?
That's why Ivy's gonna help us.
She loves plants.
I'm pretty sure they're getting, the plants are like getting
tortured right now, making that venom.
What do we get?
Health?
Armor?
Okay, armor.
Nice.
Don't worry, Ivy!
We're gonna commit...
I don't know if that is considered eco-terrorism.
I don't even...
No, because we're saving the plants.
No, no, we're good people.
Yes, we're good people.
We're good people this time.
Where the fuck is the terminal?
Oh, there it is.
How do I...
How do I do this?
Where the fuck?
Oh, there it is.
I'm going to need something to get over this ravine.
How?
What did I do?
Oh, my ship!
The bat ship!
Whoa!
Why didn't you give me this earlier?
Should I just pick this up?
The line launcher.
That's right!
I can go back and do all this stuff that needs this.
But I won't.
Yay.
Where is Ivy?
Locate poison Ivy using the Thermo Trail.
Yeah, where is it?
That 24%.
I guess like...
Oh, the closer I get, the high percentage.
It's back this way.
I guess I could get that one-wheeler trophy.
I'll give you guys a one.
I'll give you guys, like, a plus one.
Don't worry.
Where is it?
Here?
It's here.
You gotta see?
I'm a good person.
I gave you guys that one.
Oh
Only oh only because it's I have to go here anyway The only
reason is because I have to be here Poison Abbey we're here
to save your plants.
I'm here now my poor darling Yes, I know he's found us but I
won't let him hurt you.
I'll kill him first.
Muddy.
I know Dr. Young mutated these plants to produce venom.
Yes.
And I heard it through the grapevine the evil woman paid the
price.
I need you to help me create an antidote.
Why should I?
Let Joker have his fun.
I'll enjoy watching you squirm.
Ow!
Are you still wearing a shirt?
Every plant on this island will get the same.
I mean as if like why is she wearing her like green outfit?
Growing deep in Arkham Island.
Only it can counter the effects of this time story.
Where do I find it?
Oh, and Killer Crocs lair.
You didn't think it would be easy, did you?
I mean her fucking plant outfit!
What is it?
you next and i'll be waiting is that it that's just her
interaction she's just gonna give me like
exposition we're not gonna do anything we're not gonna fight
her she's like so important i need to find a way into killer
croc's lair it's somewhere below arkham island there's
nothing on the system about where he's kept i found a door
near the bat cave but it's shut tight there's got to be
another way in i left guard cash in the mansion i'll see if
you can shed some light on where Crocs kept.
Asalondas, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Save the bird.
Just let the innocent people die.
Okay, look.
Sometimes... Wait, what the fuck?
We don't have guns, though.
Can I just do this?
Alright, who's next?
Who's next?
Come on!
You can't dodge this forever!
That's right.
All right, get over here.
Nice.
All right, you know what?
By the, like, the eighth guy.
Look, he lined up, too.
They're like, me, my turn, my turn.
They're like, it's my turn.
All right, next is your turn.
Get over here.
Last guy.
Come on.
You can't dodge this forever.
Shout.
Hold on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mommy.
Look at that.
It's that easy.
Hoop.
They didn't put their stats on intellect.
That's for sure.
Alright.
We gotta collect plant spores from Killer Crocs.
Talk to... Where the fuck is that?
Is that outside of Gotham?
Oh, it is.
It's at the Gotham Mansion.
Alright, how do I get out of here?
I don't remember.
This way?
Yes, this way.
Nice.
It was that easy.
Where are the rats?
Oh, I solved it.
You found that one too?
Humpty Dumpty.
Wait, I didn't know there's a Humpty Dumpty.
An obese, bald man named Humpty Dumpty is for his egg-like
form.
Humpty Dum...
Humphrey Dumpler is obsessed.
Okay, now that's just her parents being cruel.
It's like...
This is just his parents' fault.
Humpty Dumpler is obsessed with taking things apart and
putting them back together.
His crimes at first were minor break-ins, leading to
small...
Like, you would...
The fuck's that fat Mario!
Holy shit, bro!
His name is already a Humphrey Dumpler!
You don't have to do that to him!
You set up for failure, yeah!
Functioning due to Dumpler's inability adequately
reassembled them after taking them apart, but soon his
obsession grew to the point that major disasters occurred in
Gotham, and Dumpler's crimes also extended to a gruesome
attempt to fix his abusive grandmother by the submarine whoa
and then tempting a frankenstein-like reassembly outcome he
is a model inmate his quiet nature imposing physique bearing
him to the madness surrounding him jesus he just wants to
fucking take things apart that's all he wants to do what did
he fucking debut 2003
ritualized child through this bro this person just had a
really fucking hard life His parents named him Humphrey
Dumpler!
What is that his fault?
His parents literally named him Humphrey Dumpler.
Alright, we gotta go.
We gotta go into the vent.
Apparently, there you go.
Vent time.
I'm gonna find some rats.
Where's the rat catcher?
No rats here.
Where's the fucking rats?
Oh my god there's no rats anywhere Look down in vent There's
another vent
Where It's a sewer No rats in here Scan the broken vent Is
that where the rat is?
Liars This vent in front of me Is that a vent?
all right we'll never figure this out i gave up already
i gave up
we'll never figure it out
let's see we'll just go back downstairs and then wait
there's a person there bro i'm not even thinking about you
right now I want to kill this one guy that's underneath.
The rats?
Wait, this is a...
This is a sewer.
I should be coming here.
Oh, dang!
I found the trophy!
Nice.
Okay, now I need to remember how to get out of here.
This way?
No.
Where am I?
Oh no.
Okay, I thought like it's the cliff is just gonna start.
I literally thought like it's just gonna fall on me.
I was like, oh fuck, I might have fucked up.
Alright.
Where the fuck?
Where?
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Where's the exit?
Guys!
okay no that's the entrance the exit is like here okay i
need to jump here this must be the exit right yeah okay here
i'm not lost i'm not lost guys i figured it out where am i
hello can i go back up no okay yeah i can't do this here
okay and then no oh
here oh i figured out
yay oh it's the rat again wait no i didn't figure it out
well yeah i figured it out out okay we need a we didn't find
the rat the rats up here rats rats rats where the fuck is
the rats it's in this bed somewhere look down where do I
look down here oh there it is we did it we beat the rats
once employed as an actual rat catcher in Gotham Otis
Flemingon soon started using his natural gift and affinity
with an ability to control rats to stage a variety of crimes
eventually his control over the vermin grew until he
threatened Gotham City with a variable army of rodents.
Incarcerated many times at Blackgate, he's able to do as
much damage within prisons and without using his loyal pets
to relay messages and transport materials outside the maze
of ventilation ducts that wind through the giant prison.
Oh wait, how tall is he though?
I put 11.
Oh, he lives in the sewer.
Poor guy.
Alright, you guys get to look at him.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
I'll bear back i'm
back if we're buddy all right let's beat them up
all right oh he's so trapped oh no i'm so trapped oh no get
over here oh no i'm so trapped get up get up bitch goodbye
Wait, how is he... Come on, I need to pull you in.
I will pull you into the water if it's the last thing I do.
Whoops, sorry, I couldn't aim.
Come on, you can't stay up there forever.
Oh my god, they actually programmed it, so I can't, like,
electrocute them.
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
I guess I'll do this then.
I guess I'll do it the hard way.
Okay.
I guess I'll do it this way.
Do you guys know they're planning on rebooting DC Comics
again?
I don't even know how many times they rebooted the fucking
DC lore.
Again?
Yeah, again.
Alright, goodbye.
How many times have they rebooted DC?
universe anyway all right let's see no no i'm not no i'm not
i just got your gift up there what did my sonic thing go i
was gonna say where did it go
no come on let me Get down!
Get down!
Yes, there you go.
Silent take down.
It's been rebooted five times.
I think that's like one of the biggest issues.
One of the biggest issues is just rebooted so many times
that you don't know which is the real like that.
Like, you know, it gets boring because it's the... How many
times are we going to watch Batman's parents die?
Like at that rate.
How many times do we watch his die I'm gonna go goodbye
new new new new 52 I swear to God if this one guy ruins at
all.
They better not wreak on badmints underwear.
I swear.
If they take away his underwear, I'm out.
I want him dead.
The fuck is...
You didn't do anything?
You didn't even do anything either.
You can't blame that on me.
What the fuck?
You're a little tight.
Wait, what?
I thought you were against this, Ivy.
Shall I give her another?
I think she wants it.
I was hoping for a 40-foot killer plant, but you don't
always get what you want, do you?
Oh, shit.
Is she beefed up now?
Is she going to be a domi-mommy now?
It's like those like the, you know, like those like
bodybuilders, oh my gosh, the wood Women bodybuilding
competitions go so fucking hard.
Oh my god.
She's gonna be like those women bodybuilders.
Where do I go?
Collect plants.
How do I get out of here then?
What do I do?
Can I just cut it with my batter at him?
Maybe my fist can cut it.
Where the fuck?
Where do I go then?
Where do I go back?
Drop down?
There's a down?
Oh,
there's a down.
Sorry, I forgot where down is.
Alright, nice.
Go up.
This way.
Bro, I swear, if she is not...
If she is not swole as fuck, like, the women bodybuilder
competition, then they've...
Then they've missed a point.
They missed a mark.
Okay.
Titan must be having a different effect on Ivy.
Her plants are growing.
They'll soon be out of control.
If she's not extra hot, I'm done.
Oh, no!
Wait, are they...
Oh, no, did they kill them?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I was gonna say...
I thought they were gonna make them swole.
That pod appears to contain similar spores to the ones Ivy
used to attack Gotham last year.
That is...
They're deadly.
I just Hit it Why can't I make a flame Bad a flame thrower A
bat flamethrower I should be able to make a bat Ow Oh it
doesn't hurt that much What the fuck How the fuck did these
guys die I should be allowed to make a bat flamethrower
Oh I can punch it Okay let me punch him first Okay
Oh Oh Okay, I'll...
I love my kids.
Just punch the plant, just punch the plant, Batman.
Wait, okay, he has XP!
I'm gonna punch all the plants.
I guess.
Fuck the environment, but in-game.
There we go.
Oh my god, oh, it's just 25 XP.
It's not that much, actually.
Fist the...
No!
Batman just fist the plant.
Batman.
Why so serious, Batman?
Just fist a plant.
There we go.
But it adds up, Toki.
No, I feel like this is just some fucking somebody sick
fetish right now.
Oh, shit.
All right.
Like how it kills him.
all right let's see you know i realized i found out that
before like disney bought marvel and made all the fucking
disney movies uh okay i gotta go this way right um the only
popular characters in marvel was like spider-man and was
just spider-man the x-men and wolver i mean wolverine is
practically a fucking x-men and like dc basically had the
fucking monopoly really for DC hero for the hero market.
And now everything has to be a fucking emce- the- was it?
Has to be like a- a universe- What was the word?
A cinematic universe?
Now everything has to be a goddamn cinematic universe.
I'm so tired of cinematic universe.
Just let it end.
Let it end!
I feel like downstairs is poison.
Whoops.
I'm tired of MCU's I'm tired of cinematic universes Let
things end Who gives a fuck about nostalgia I don't care
How do I go?
Oh back here, okay Where do I go there?
Can I climb on TV?
Wee Guys, I can't climb on TVs.
Oh, wait.
I'm up here now.
How did I get up here?
Where am I?
What do I do?
Oh.
Balcony.
Okay.
I looked around.
Alright.
Question mark.
Maybe here?
I head across here?
No, that's a podium.
God damn it.
That's a podium.
That's a fucking...
Chloe.
Where do I drop?
Oh, I can drop here.
Alright, nice.
Can I punch...
Can I fist this flat?
No, wait.
Oh, this way.
Okay.
Go up here.
I'm tired of nostalgia bait.
It's so stupid.
Did you guys know they released new Star Wars stuff again?
I'm so tired.
Please.
Where do I go?
Here?
I guess so.
I've lost track of how many fucking...
Uh...
What the fuck?
I lost track of how many fucking Star Wars shit they've made
already.
Maybe here?
Yeah.
I was like looking at Disney.
Please!
Is that a fuck?
Okay, nice.
That counts.
Okay, that counts.
I take this.
This way.
That counts.
No!
Let me exploit!
Oh, hey.
Let me exploit it.
Oh, nice.
That works.
Yay!
That's nice.
Oh, hey guys.
I figured you'd be here about now.
What's the deal with the plants?
It's complicated.
Let me guess.
Poison Ivy.
She teamed up with Joker.
All that matters.
I have no idea how to do this legit.
I'm glad that I've exploited my way into this.
There's always a butt, isn't there?
Where do you keep Killer Croc?
I found a door in the sewers, but it's sealed shut.
That monster's got his own special cell.
treatment elevator goes right down to an old sewer he just
dropped meat down there every day or so and try to forget
about it it's locked off more security than the joker you
won't get in without the warden's permission he has the
codes i have the codes thanks cash stay here and do not go
near the plants how do you like not go near they're
literally everywhere okay i like how someone was saying like
oh their people their companies are too scared to do
anything but nostalgia bait because they don't want to make
anything new they're too scared of spending money that
they're losing money it's so stupid okay okay can access to
killer crocs there via intensive treatment how to get out of
here god damn it okay i need to figure out how to get out of
here it's so dumb Because they're too scared of spending
money On experimenting That they end up making it worse So
like, what's the point?
I don't get out of here now I've already exploded my way to
here But now I don't know how to get there I guess like This
way?
I'm lost
Um Um Whoops Yeah!
Yes!
That's what I like!
I did it!
I figured it out.
The cheese.
Cheezed my way out, and that's how I like it.
Alright, grapple here.
Nice.
That was just that easy.
Like you said, this island has been well and truly buried.
Oh well.
We got to go.
Over here.
I guess I can go from the right side.
I'll go right side.
Whee!
Any more plants that would like the back treatment?
50% off!
Here I go.
Oh, this one plant.
You thought you could get away.
Boop.
Nice.
Tell your friends.
All right, we got fist this one, too.
Boop.
Nice.
All right.
Sit this way.
Okay, here.
I might even have 50% of this game.
What the fuck?
Why are they wearing jackets now?
See?
I told... See?
The Joker's great!
Their men was cold and the Joker gave them jackets, guys.
Look at that.
Now it's bowling time.
Bowling!
Nice.
Three.
I take this.
Look at that.
Joker is so considerate, guys.
They literally gave them jackets because he doesn't want
them to be cold.
Your boss would never...
He's so nice.
I know, right?
He's so nice!
Nah, that's fucking right.
I gotta make sure, like...
Oh, nice, I took his... I took his fucking taser all the
way.
Oh, I wanted to use the weapon for that one time, but not
the other time.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'll counter that.
How can I throw my batter-ems?
Wait, how did he pick that up?
Alright, nope.
That's fucking right.
Counter.
How did I counter that?
No!
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no, no.
That's fucking right.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get away from me!
Okay.
Now I'm just gonna go.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop.
He can die eventually, right?
That's right.
He'll die eventually.
There's no way you can live through all these battle radons.
Simple physics!
Okay, now I'm just gonna...
Now you're just pissing me off.
Okay.
You've lived long enough.
Now I see it.
Now you don't...
There was a sniper up on the roof.
He got there somehow.
I'll find a way.
Where's the sniper?
This guy?
Oh, that guy is the sniper.
Okay.
I mean, I can literally just go.
I can just climb.
Batman, climb.
I can't just climb.
Alright.
That's not fair.
I thought I could just climb.
understand you mean i can't just climb everything who would
have thought i can't just climb everything
goodbye he's not a spy there we no oh wait no i can't just
get up there what if i line this i'm there must be an
exploit Oh, he sees me.
No, he doesn't.
Okay, there must be...
There's always an exploit.
God damn it.
How the fuck do I get across?
Go up the tower?
This tower?
Okay, this must be the tower.
Ew.
Okay.
Oh, there is.
There's always an exploit.
I did not see that!
Holy shit!
Joker, you need to invest in better goons.
They're not gonna lie.
I love 2010 NPCs.
It made me feel so smart.
It's dark out.
Then don't be a fucking sniper!
Oh, Shit.
Structural integrity.
I'm seeing seismic activity.
Ivy's plants are taking hold.
I've got to stop them before the entire island is under her
control.
If she is not swole as fuck, then this game's a 9 out of 10.
No swole Ivy.
It doesn't make sense.
Why is she not swole, but the goons are?
I don't understand.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, no.
Am I gonna be lost again?
I think I'm gonna be lost again.
Okay, I need to go here.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna be lost again.
If she is, I swear I'm gonna lose a Batman.
Plants can be swole.
What the fuck are you talking about?
There's thick plants.
Plants can be plump.
okay let's see i need to figure out how to do this oh my god
this is a john ass vent whoop okay this way yeah have you
seen peaches are they ready raises just finishing his off
now good let's test him out no no i'm still up whoa don't
worry i'm pretty sure Joker has Joker insurance, right?
All right.
Wait, no more inverted takedowns?
Wait, did he fucked up all the Gorgos?
Ow.
Nope, nope.
There's no way he exploded this one, right?
He exploded this one.
There's no...
Whoa, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
There's no way they saw me, guys.
Watch this.
Bowling time.
Two.
Okay, there you go.
There's no way they saw me here.
What the fuck?
I'm in the corner!
This is...
This is fucking legal!
Who shot me?
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, dude, no.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe they saw me.
Okay, this time I got this.
I can do this.
I can do this this time.
I don't need no gargoyle.
I don't need no gargoyles.
The gargoyles are not a crutch for me.
It's not a crutch, I swear.
I can't believe they're learning.
I can't believe the AIs are learning.
This isn't fair.
How do you afford all these guns?
There you go.
God damn it, now I actually have to stealth.
Can I just, like, keep killing them here?
an event
it's not a crutch i swear okay wait
okay i'll just have them all over here and i'll beat them up
what do we do now shut up and keep looking it's okay it's
okay they'll have to turn around someday right not everybody
totally better my Thank you.
Thank you.
That's okay.
They have to turn around soon, right?
Come on.
Turn around.
Alright.
That's fine.
It's fine.
As long as Joker doesn't ghost me again, we're fine.
Because then he doesn't do any ghosting.
Oh my god, look at that.
They're back to back.
They're covered his back.
What are these AIs?
He's so smart.
Oh.
He doesn't see me right?
Oh no, he doesn't see.
Definitely doesn't see me.
Alright, come on.
Come up.
That's fucking right.
Go closer to your friend.
Oh fuck.
No, that's not cool.
That's not fair.
Why are you over here?
Oh, okay.
Ooh!
There's a seed.
It's okay!
Okay.
Back up, Bakko.
It's not a crutch, I swear!
The gargoyles are not a crutch!
I swear to God!
Okay.
Alright.
We can do this.
Oh!
I have an idea!
Okay.
I'm gonna tag this.
I have an idea.
Guys!
I figured it out.
I'm gonna set up a trap.
Okay, and then...
And then...
Okay.
Wait, I can't use this here.
Wait, I can't- I can't- okay.
It's okay.
It's fine.
I just realized I cannot use the explosives while in the
vent, but it's okay.
He walked into my trap.
He was alone.
There we go.
It's that easy.
My trap.
Being alone.
Alright, don't worry.
Don't worry.
He doesn't know.
There's no way he knows.
Yes!
There's no way.
There's no way they knew.
He's alone!
You're alone!
I'm coming for you!
You have no friends!
This is the perfect cover!
Oh shit.
Wait, that's not great.
Never mind.
Yes.
friends now.
He has friends now, guys.
That's not good.
Wait, is it bowling time?
Wait, wait, it's bowling time.
Okay.
Whoa.
No, no, don't turn back.
No, no, no.
Don't turn back.
Don't huddle up.
This is not among us.
Stop huddling.
It's not fun.
Oh, hey, look at my legs, though.
Holy shit.
Look at how thick my thighs are, though.
Hooker hired the finest goons with exactly 45 degrees of...
What?
No!
Do not!
I swear!
What did he...
Why was he paranoid?
Someone held that baby.
No!
I can't believe you were paranoid!
We were so close!
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, I can't believe it Why were you paranoid?
I don't understand
Like there was no reason to be paranoid
All I'm saying was there was no reason for him to be that
scary
I'm just gonna kill this guy.
Okay.
We got this.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is it.
This is the try.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna start painting.
No.
No!
It's fine.
Not crutch.
Um, it's fine.
It's so fine.
We're so fine.
Okay.
If I use...
If I use this batteram...
Boom.
There we go.
dangerous he'll ruin everything and then and then i'll use
this one
oops all right i'm gonna make sure the other guy all right
come on one of you must be a loner
one of you must not have friends come on you can't all come
on you can't all be gone good good side together Okay, him.
Him.
That's second, right?
Okay.
See, I told you.
What do you mean this is painful to watch?
We're fucking gaming!
We're gaming right now!
Okay, he's...
Is he alone or two?
What is this fucking buddy system shit right now?
Okay.
who's not gonna head over there all right you're gonna head
over there okay you're gonna check each other out oh this
guy he's not going to okay unless oh my god why are you
doing checking that what are you doing all your friends are
over there this guy's a loner but I can't I can't fucking
separate him from the rest okay i'm gonna put this here no
it didn't no it didn't actual thank you the super chat thank
you thank you doki gave me i'm doing my best okay are y'all
just gonna be over there holy they're huddled up together
this is legal all right what is it
doing okay what the whoops oh my god he's so paranoid I'm
gonna leave
Why are they all grouped up?
Where are you?
Hell with this Stop grouping up!
Fuck the buddy system!
It's not worth it!
Oh my god, they're actually holding hands.
They're actually holding hands!
What the fuck is this bullshit?
Wait, they're actually...
This is stupid.
They're holding hands.
Come on.
No!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No.
You can't come up here.
I'm fucking on the ceiling.
Look at them.
There's no way.
What do you mean?
How did I miss that?
Okay.
I got him up.
He's still in that...
Fuck, he's still camping.
fucking camping.
Okay, this, okay.
Alright.
Come on, leave.
God, you're so paranoid.
This one guy.
I'm just gonna bone rush him.
I'm just gonna fucking bone.
There's no way he can fucking kill me.
He's just one guy.
Alright.
This is it.
I I can do this.
Watch.
I'm gonna bone rush him.
Okay.
It worked.
I told you, there's no way.
I told you.
There's no way.
See, eventually they'll split up.
Please!
No!
I told you, they'll split up.
There's no way.
I told you, they'll split up eventually.
They'll split.
I told you.
The buddy system will eventually fail.
There we go.
The buddy system will fail!
I knew it.
Oh, I don't think I'm gonna blow this correctly.
That's fine.
Oh.
No.
There you go.
The light up!
The
light up!
Ah!
I Don't find that I missed that How?
I went between them How is that possible?
How can you go between them, Doki?
Oh my god They're leaving the buddy system This is it No
No Wait.
Okay.
They're leaving the buddy system.
I knew it!
The buddy system is in forever!
Okay.
Alright.
I just gotta kill him.
This building is ours.
Joker said so.
Yes!
Abaco!
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
There's no way I can best.
There's no way I can best!
That's fucking right!
Bam!
There we go.
I did it.
That's how you do it.
That's how you stealth.
That's how you stealth guys.
Any questions?
Any questions, guys?
I'm willing to...
I'm here all day.
Alright, how the fuck do I unlock this?
It is inside.
The stealthiest bird out there.
Where the fuck is the code thing for this?
How the hell the hell am I supposed to hack this?
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
Follows execution.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No problem.
Oh, I could have done this and be like, peekaboo.
What the fuck do I?
Oh, it's over here.
All right.
Joker gas time.
Let's see.
It should be here.
What?
what
what okay oh this
wait there's a timer oh sorry I didn't realize I actually
didn't realize there's been a timer this entire time okay
nice oh my god where the fuck is this one There we go.
Oh, this one's harder.
Oh, no.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
That one was so difficult.
I couldn't find it.
It's okay.
I did it.
First try.
First fucking try.
Can't believe there was a timer this entire time.
I was definitely not paying attention.
Links, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
that's amazing see and on the first try i know oh my god how
does she do it how the does she do it guys truly a gamer of
her generation basically this the hackers are getting a bit
hard though all right yes i had to make sure i had to make
sure i was able to go in Wait, what's this for?
There's nothing in here.
It's a point of hacking here if there's nothing here.
What the fuck?
I felt cheated out of this.
Oh my god, I felt cheated out of this area.
Scan the picture?
Oh shit, was this a riddle?
Oh.
Okay.
I didn't realize there was a riddle here.
Riddle me this.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Did anyone catch the game last night?
Huh?
Uh...
What?
Huh?
Why is it in the back car?
Joker!
What?
Oh my god!
God, it's so cool!
Oh my god, it's so cool!
I get to play Joker!
Oh my god, it's like...
Yeah, Roboversa!
Brickham
Asylum was run by the criminals.
Just got to check your prisoner, dear.
Whatever, just be quick.
Whoa!
No, he's not.
We really should.
She feels sorry for him.
He never fully got over his parents' death.
It left him quite insane.
Oh my god, Mastery dropped.
Thank you for the 50.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
We appreciate it.
How does he know my identity?
Oh, oh.
He's all yours, Joker.
Am I using my Bruce Wayne voice?
Come on, Mr. J, we're ready.
No, put me like, I want to be the Joker.
Oh.
Let's start the party with a bag.
Oh, what?
I don't...
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Rest in peace, Bruce Wade.
Oh, shit.
How the fuck was I supposed to know I was supposed to die?
Whoa.
Wait, what?
I thought it was still a cutscene.
I thought we were still in a cutscene.
Are you okay, Batman?
He is not okay.
What am I...
I guess I'll fly here.
Oh, shit.
I don't know where to fly to.
That exploited?
No.
What?
Oh, line?
Oh, I had my gadgets.
I didn't know I had my gadgets.
I didn't know I had my gadgets with me.
I thought, like...
What are you doing, little bat?
Okay, it's time.
Go up.
What?
How?
I was so fast.
Come on.
That was bullshit.
That was fucking bullshit.
What?
Oh my god.
Okay, that was also bullshit.
Okay, here you go.
It's a joke there is no middle stick.
You fuckers, I actually thought I fucked up.
I actually thought I fucked up.
I was like, I thought you've been like middle button, you
know, like the middle mouse button.
Oh my god, do we have to dodge?
You fucker, I actually thought I fucked it up.
Gotta get him out of here.
Oh, the chimney saw, I was like, no, there was a middle
mouse, buddy!
What?
No!
I actually did crash!
God damn it!
I actually did crash.
No!
The real crash.
But holy shit, the Joker thing, glitch thing actually scared
the shit out of me.
I was like, what the fuck?
I was like, oh my god, is my PC actually done for real real
now?
I was like Oh fuck Maybe my PC is finally Rest in peace for
reals Maybe if I had a middle stick button
Okay where did it leave me off Where did I die
Okay it's not that bad Okay thank God Oh my god thank God I
actually hit a safe point
am i stuck there wait am i oh my god am i locked no way okay
there's no way there's no way i'm bugged right there
cheater thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
hello there's no way there's no fucking way i'm i i would i
cannot progress
No, no, no, no, no, we don't know, no, we don't know, we
have softlock, please.
Middle bass button, where are you?
Where are you?
Okay, okay, there's no way I'm actually softlocked here,
there's no fucking way.
Okay Wait, okay, I'm out of here.
I'm out of here.
We're okay.
We're okay We're okay guys We made it past that one area Oh
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Thank you fucking god.
We're so back We're so back.
We're so back.
We are so back How do I climb Climb Climb
Almost every patient sent to him and boast empty beds in all
his wards Okay, it's not over yet.
It's not over.
Okay.
I can't because you're the scarecrow for our reason.
Come on, please.
Oh, God, okay.
You can't kill me.
I'm you.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Can you make sure I don't die here?
Bro, this trip is freaking me out, bro.
I can't see if we're done.
Okay.
Nice.
I think you need a little more.
Huh?
Tell me what you have left to beat.
Show me soon.
No, I have to do this again.
Don't!
No, Scarecrow!
This is not good for my brain, my brain chemistry in the
end.
There's no way that the Scarecrow toxins is like good for
the brain.
What are the long-term effects from the fear toxins?
Like, like brain chemistry-wise.
Yeah, this is a very bad trip right now.
Can I just punch you in?
Oh.
They're just skeletons.
Wait, are you like...
Do I need a batterang mu?
Are you gonna charge?
Are you a batteram skellies?
Oh, he is the batteram skellies.
Wait, wait!
Wait!
It still works.
Guys, it still works, guys.
It still works, okay?
It's still okay.
Like, I still got it, okay.
That's failed successfully.
I don't know if I was supposed to know!
I didn't know!
I didn't know any better around this.
him.
Really dodged him.
I'm alive still.
Yeah.
Easy.
Bring me back to the Joker.
How are you doing this?
Oh my god, you have eyes.
More!
Bro!
What the fuck is wrong?
with me did I like get used to it bro I think like I'm just
like so used to toxins now I'm bad bad all right nice
weekend love love all right what do we get guys what should
our upgrades be guys we
already have remote battered did you guys see that all the
times i fucking was successfully able to get to hit people
with my batarans twin batarans okay i'll get twin how do i
do this so let aim lt nrt okay nice okay that should be okay
uh it's this way guys all the times i've successfully you
know my targets.
Brains, gods, the brain cheat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, he has eyes.
I just dropped down?
It'll be alright if I just dropped down, right?
What will happen if I just fall down?
Yeah, see?
It'll be fine.
like why am i scared i can just do this and then boom easy
look at that
did i get there oh here there's stairs
all right don't worry i can use my double batter ends for
this Watch this.
Bam!
Oh!
Look at that!
Get over here!
You can't five second roll!
No gun!
Five second roll!
All right.
Look at that.
I told you.
Successfully.
I told you I can do this successfully.
Oh, this is when she was Harley and Quinzel?
Tell me.
And if you don't mind my saying, beautifulness.
Oh yeah, like no doctor has ever said that.
Damn Joker.
He's such a Rizler.
Oh my god, he knows how to charm a woman.
If he was a streamer, he would have so much Akasupas.
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Depending on the version of Toxin, Harley uses it
recreationally.
Makes sense you can build.
Yeah, I was going to say, I'm pretty sure I built like a
tolerance or some shit by then what is this you scan no
thank you batman for the hunt for the akasupa
i feel like you know what i feel like if he streamed this
crime he would he he would have so many fans on the dark web
all right let's see hacking time
It's like how, like, women, some women, like, and men, like,
send, like, letters to, like...
Wait, what the fuck?
What?
Why am I not getting... Okay.
You know how, like, some women, men send, like, love letters
to, like, serial killers in prison?
Like, he'd be able to find somebody.
Oh, no, oh, no, oh, no, I can't find it.
I can't find it.
I can't.
Oh, here you go.
Last three seconds.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah.
A lot of like serial killers have like wives and like have
have like outside wives and husbands.
It was like this famous like there was like a murder or
something that was like on trial and then like I don't know
if it was a guy or girl.
And then I think it was like fangirls where like oh my god
he's so hot he can't be a murder.
Look at him.
He's just misunderstood.
He's so hot though.
And I'm just like what the fuck is her?
I was just like, what the fuck?
Bro!
No, it wasn't.
It was someone recent, too.
I can fix him.
Even though he murdered so many women, he wouldn't murder
me.
Like, what the fuck?
Holy shit.
Bro.
Like, please.
Okay, it's building.
time.
Wait, I don't need a bullet.
I can use two.
Nice.
Okay, I can keep doing it.
Oh, he's getting guns!
I forgot!
Oh!
That's right.
No guns.
Okay.
There's no guns.
I can fly.
It does.
It happens a lot more.
Like, a lot more frequently than you expect.
Get out.
No gun.
This is a fair match.
Okay.
That's fucking hard.
Get over here.
Get over here!
Oh shit.
It's okay.
Gotta dodge all these guys.
Throw, throw, throw!
Throw!
Okay.
We gotta get him out of here.
I can't do a takedown!
They're all trying to get the gun!
No.
No gun for you.
No!
There's too many people!
Okay, one of you guys would let me do a finish, right?
Nice, we're fine.
Why can't I get a gun?
I know, like, I keep asking about it, but I just want gun.
Like, it can be a non-lethal gun, you know?
Like, it's a bullet that just stops, like, that just, like,
pinches the skin, and it hurts a little bit.
Like, it stuns you.
Yeah, stun guns.
stun guns aren't lethal Batman why can't I have a better gun
a better stun yeah stun guns aren't lethal that's different
all right is there anything here that I need to look at oh
the real earth um okay actually maybe not
Hmm.
Good question.
Here?
Yeah, it's here.
What a great question.
Wait, what?
Where am I?
Huh?
You'll be back, and I'll kill him.
Then cash, then you.
I don't think like I feel like as a guard you would want to
be like nice to them so like because like they're always
breaking out right so they're always breaking you know
they're always breaking out there's no like if they break
out it's like whenever they do break out so like I feel like
at that point you'd want to be nice to them so like so so
why would you like you know be antagonistic to them when you
know they're gonna fucking break out
Okay, all I'm saying is that eventually Eventually they're
gonna get out My game crashed
So like why would you ever be like antagonistic to the
villains
What okay but like if you're more mean to them then they'll
be like they're gonna like you know if they're gonna kill
you anyway okay so like you're going in thinking these
villains are gonna kill you anyway but like if you're like
extra mean to them then they're gonna make it more painful
more slow and painful you know so if you're nice to them
they'll be like you know what you were nice to me oh yeah
we'll we'll let it end quick you know it'll be quick but
instead because cash was
What?
One step closer and this goes into the water.
I feel like the water's already tainted.
I'm out of Joker's shit in there.
Darkest nightmares.
And you will never reach your precious venom roots.
Oh no, not the water.
Oh shit!
Wait, is he gonna beat him?
Oh!
looking access to the killer crocs there where is that okay
this way oh my okay i don't think he can breathe down there
so like he could have been he might as well be dead i don't
know i don't know if he could actually like breathe down
like i don't know no i can't swim what are you fucking sonic
God damn it.
I can't swim, guys.
Why can't you swim?
Perfect time for the underweight gas mask.
Thank you for the super chat, Jonathan.
Thank you.
What's the point of you can't swim, Batman?
Is this why Aquaman's on the team?
Is he your, like, token swim boy?
swim so you got Aquaman?
He's carrying too much muscle, Toki.
Don't understand.
Oracle, I'm heading into Crocs' lair to collect the plant
scores Ivy spoke about.
He's in some kind of old sewer network.
Send me the schematics.
It's like a maze down here.
There's nothing on record.
Bruce, are you sure about this?
Sounds like a suicide mission.
Holy chill, Toki.
No one cares about Aquaman until the aquaman moved until
like what's his name jason samoa fucking played aquaman
croc's just an animal and animals just need traps and the
right bait i'll be fine oh that's a bigger okay all right oh
sorry mamoa i'm sorry i'm sorry jason mamoa
slowly as possible.
Whoa, where is he?
But all I'm saying, no one cared about him until Jason Mamoa
was...
Until Jason Mamoa was Batman.
Not Batman, was Hawk of Man.
That'll be fine.
Is he gonna do Eat Me?
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
I remember he wanted to, like, he was auditioning for
another hello my back oh no I'm refreshing I don't know my
back okay okay give me a sec I need a guys I have I'm on
wi-fi I don't know I don't know I don't know I don't know if
like i don't know what's going on with my with my connection
i'm on wi-fi now
oh my god i can't believe i'm on wi-fi holy oh my god give
me a sec i'm trying to i i'm not i'm not alive on screen
right now i'm on wi-fi right now so give me a sec everybody
Give me a sec.
Holy shit.
I can't believe I'm on Wi-Fi.
I can't believe I have been on Wi-Fi in fucking forever.
Holy shit.
All right, let's see.
I'm connecting.
Please connect.
How could I?
What do you mean I can't connect?
What do you mean?
Imagine thinking of Super Chat.
Maybe the Wi-Fi is the ransom mail.
I can't believe I'm on fucking Wi-Fi.
Oh my god.
Alright, how do I do this?
Connect.
Why are you not connecting?
Is it because I'm on Wi-Fi?
Guys, I'm trying to figure this out.
Jason Mamoa's doing all because I talked about Jason Mamoa I
blame Jason Mamoa I fucking blame him it's all his fucking
fault what the fuck what happened to my direct connection
what actually happened bro why can't I connect with a PC
bro what do you mean what do you mean i can't connect to
this what is my all right let's see what the fuck is this
okay all right maybe i might change my thing here guys give
you technical difficulties right now we are experiencing
some turbulence at the moment so give me a sec
oh i'm alive there we go i figured it out it's wi-fi gaming
time it's like it's wi-fi gaming time i can't believe i'm on
wi-fi now all right here we go all right i am on wi-fi let's
hope that this will be okay Oh, why you told me to run?!
What the fuck?!
I forgot about running!
Joy feasting on you!
Oh my god.
I don't know what went wrong, but we're gonna be Wi-Fi
gamers until we've...
Until... until my direct connection comes back.
Alright, where am I?
Where am I?
Yeah?
Anyway, go here, right?
No, I go here.
We go here.
Okay, I have to run again.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep,
here I'll go.
All right, don't worry, I'll fucking fix chat later.
There were so many things going around.
It's Wi-Fi meta now!
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
okay throw a batter at why do I just throw a batter am why
okay that's not a batter am that's not about that's
a good thing it's a good thing because then that means
because then that means I can fix the chat you know that's
what I wanted to do I wanted to fix chat guys good it's good
it's alright oh
Okay, we're back.
We're back.
We're we're fucking back.
Oh, whoops.
Okay.
Nice.
We did it.
There we go.
I figured it out.
Guys, I figured it out.
Here we go.
Everything is fine.
We figured it all out.
Nothing to worry about.
Like we never left.
There we go.
Easy.
So easy.
Back compute.
Everything is gold.
It's like if anything wrong can happen, that's happening,
it's happening today.
Nice.
Let me gather this.
And my computer is slowly dying.
My internet is slowly dying too.
We're here for the ride.
Am I halfway through this game yet?
Murphy's Law and Fall In Fact.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, so we're here.
Wait, what?
Ah!
What do you mean?
What happened?!
Batman!
Why did it curve Batman?
Why did it curve?
Why the fuck?
You don't need to curve the bullet!
Wait, what is this behind me?
Okay.
There we go.
It's normal to curve.
Okay, nice.
Now, I actually don't even know how much...
You guys have given me so many conflicting answers.
I actually don't even know how much I have left.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, my guys.
Alright, there you go.
I trust my doctor.
I feel like I can just crouch, walk as fast.
Are we 75% done?
Wait, I can actually finish this today.
Okay.
Thank God.
Technically, I can finish this today if it's 75%.
Alright, we're in it for the long haul.
We went through so many things together, guys.
Why did he go that way?
Okay.
I was like, why are you...
I mean, that's fine.
Yeah, I was like, why did he go that way?
Got her.
Hey, what are you that?
Is he stupid?
all right come on face me oh nice no no no no no no no i was
gonna take me back into the pit all right yay
this way well not this way i can find you batman i mean it's
not that hard oh
way he's gonna cut this real quick i mean it's not that
difficult to find me just like poke your head out a little
bit and you'll see me oh no what is he gonna do fucking come
up and bite me he smells my wi-fi connection
i guess i used uh i use this
okay wait hold a to my why why which way which way am i
going the right way oh okay i was like what do you mean run
where where where oh there no oh shit okay it hit okay i was
gonna be like worth it by battery Okay, my battery had hit
the wall, but it still counted.
That's okay.
I take those.
What?
Run?
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
Okay.
This way.
Oh, my God.
This is so scary.
I'm so paranoid right now.
He could come up at any time.
Okay, got her.
Woo!
whoo nice get her how much fucking spores do i have to get
her
all right i've got enough spores i think i get back to the
bat cave and formulate the antidote thank fucking guy oh i
get it you've activated
oracle i'm getting out of here what about croc he won't be a
problem okay nice Yeah, I don't think he'll be a problem
You're right, Batman He doesn't see Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
what the wrong way It was this way I think Yeah, it's this
way Wait, huh?
Please open that door For me Thank you thank you i really
appreciate that thank you so god damn it i hate these all
right as i was saying jason mamoa wanted to like wanted to
be a different guy oh he wanted to be um what's his name oh
my god oh shit no no no no i'm trying to i'm trying to think
he wanted to be like this anti-hero guy his name he he was
he ah lobo yes he would make a really good lobo do you know
he's a fucking nerd i didn't even realize oh my god to these
no no no no no no no he got the bad light no i met jason
jason he's a he's actually a nerd and i'll do it again jason
the moment that for the akasupa are you fucking kidding me I
have to do this all the way from the beginning fuck you
Jason Mamoa but thank you for the akasupa you're in the
akasupa
oh my god god damn it that's it can't believe it I got
fucked over because I had the line All right.
I'm good now.
Everything's fine.
I can't fucking...
Okay.
That should be all the explosions.
Can't believe I have to do this all the way back from the
beginning.
Where is he gonna pop up?
I'm so paranoid.
There you go.
Just in case.
God damn it.
I'm so far.
I still have 300 left.
Please.
Why can't I send my bat cave over?
Imagine my bat car.
Just fucking grab my bat car into the sewers.
Oh yeah, god damn it.
Okay.
Then I go... Nope.
This way?
Okay, it's this way.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
This way.
Okay, I'm retracing my steps.
I remember now.
I remember how to get back.
Nice.
Okay.
I remember exactly how to get back now.
Nope.
Now I do.
me what whoa that's not gonna stop me from running that's
not gonna stop me from running oh my gosh crash bandicoot
time why did you stop baby
okay okay now oh my god when batman is faster than the
camera i hate this okay we're good we're good we're good
we're good we're good we're good we're good
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Oh, we're not good, we're not good, we're not good.
We're not good.
My caves will be your tomb.
It's okay.
I can time this perfectly.
Nice.
I knew there was going to be water underneath, so it's not
killing.
He died.
I will find you.
Nice.
Yay!
I'm gonna take this as a win and I'm gonna use a bathroom
break.
I'll be right back.
I'll be right back Where's this?
I am here This is the back cave.
Alright, I'm gonna take this as a win and go for a bathroom
break.
I'll be right back guys
I'm back Okay, who the fuck just said chat you want to kiss
by the sewer?
Please love yourself more
Standards!
Holy shit!
Okay.
Guys, you need to have standards, guys.
Because then that, because you're watching me, and I assume
you guys have high standards, right, guys?
Because if you have low standards and you're watching me,
then that makes me a little sad.
That's like, that says a lot of bow.
Guys, you have high standards, right?
Guys!
Alright, what do we upgrade?
What's the next?
I guess batter and power.
You know what?
Yeah, batter and power.
Look at.
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Oh, in the wrong way.
Fuck, okay.
It's this way.
Yeah, just enough, I think.
Guys!
Wait, this way.
Wee!
It was not this way, guys.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm cheesing the system.
I'm cheesing it?
I'm cheesing the system, but...
Yay!
Maybe I'll...
Yes!
I did it!
Nice.
I cheesed it perfectly.
Perfectly cheesed.
As all things should be.
Alright, let's see.
Where do we go?
Oh, it's this place.
It's this way.
Alright.
Gotta go ahead this way.
Oh, shit!
Hey guys!
Whoa!
Guys, guys!
Come on!
I have two batterans.
Oh, this is the wrong battering!
Now I have two battering.
No, this is the wrong one again!
Oh, damn it.
Let me just get rid of this guy.
Alright, nice.
I did not see all of these people.
What's up, guys?
Wait, you have a gun?
Oh, my God.
Don't worry.
Darks, so slide.
Also, Joy Boys, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
A detective.
Yes, we have standards.
What the fuck are you doing with this box?
Oh, no, a toaster.
What will we do?
Oh no, he's grabbing the gun.
He's grabbing the gun.
Detective Shade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, we have standards.
But if a homie asks for a kiss, need a serious, and then the
homie will get a kiss on the serious.
Thank you for the super chat, Shane.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
I've got the mold samples.
I'm heading to the Batcave to mix up the antidote.
That's true.
You can't reject the homie.
what you're doing being even a fan of a hundred dollar fog
raw can enjoy a 12 dollar bucket of i'm the fog raw right
i'm the duck you fucking force fed and then ate the liver of
right guys
right all right i am right
guys I need a dough!
Scan and opus.
Alright, this way.
I'm in the bat cave.
That's definitely not OSHA approved.
Where am I getting all this?
This is where all the power bill went to.
Close.
It's been more difficult than I expected.
The process is slow, difficult, and doesn't produce much
antidote.
and the good news the chemical will definitely stop ivy it
may also reverse the Titan transformation I need to run some
more tests to be sure I've set the computer to create more
but I need to get out of here and find Ivy thank God her
plans have reached the Gotham River well you're right who
built this wait you guys are right who the fuck built like
workers nda johnson thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i just got back what in the world is going on
right now did my fucking i swear to god did my wi-fi die
again
no we're still alive i'm just not alive
oh shit i got an upgrade though fires up the three claws oh
i can't allow structural weaknesses to be pulled down remote
okay give me a sec we're going through a lot today we're
going through
Batman is so I used up all my luck in power world clearly I
feel like at this point I definitely used up all my lucky
power world everything that could go wrong has gone wrong
today give me a sec i'm barely connecting right now oh my
god guys give me a sec we're going back in i think connect
yes i am still on the wi-fi i am in still on the Wi-Fi right
now.
It's been pretty rough today.
It's okay.
I got third place plus one in paddle world.
It's something.
No!
Why can't I connect?
I don't understand.
How could the Wi-Fi do this to me?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
How could the Wi-Fi do this?
Up in nothing but great to the Wi-Fi.
Do I just use...
Am I going to actually use my data?
Am I...
Oh my god.
I don't understand how they could do this to me.
okay i've been nothing but i've been nothing but like
amazing to my pc what have i done wrong okay i need to make
sure i don't accidentally read out my ip i'm like okay dokey
do not read this out when you're typing this in wi-fi give
it and wi-fi take it i don't understand how could this
happen to me I just want to beat Batman Please Just let me
beat the game I'm so close to beating the game
At least we, you know At least we stopped at a good point
You know, at least you get to see that At least you get to
see No, we're beating Batman today!
Oh my god, I'm in.
I'm in.
I'm back in.
I'm back in, guys.
Oh my god.
Everything is okay.
Everything is okay, everybody.
We're back in it.
Wait, not this one.
We're back in it, guys.
Look, we're back in it.
Everything is fine.
There we go.
Alright, wait, I forgot to...
I need to tap back into my...
so I can see my chat.
Okay.
Nice.
That's Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We gotta stop Poison Ivy now.
How do I get out of here?
I guess, like, here?
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, anyway, as I was saying, who the fuck built this?
Like...
Are you guys as confused as me?
I don't know.
Who built this?
This way is blocked by plants.
I need to find another way out.
I guess this way.
There's no way Bruce Wayne did this.
Like, yeah, he beats up people.
But, like, he does not have the fucking...
He does not have, like, the work ethics to build this.
God damn it.
There's no way to let Alfred build this.
He's fucking old.
Oh.
Oh, okay, here we go.
Oh, I can finally do that wall.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
He built multiple by himself?
Bro.
Okay, Labrador.
Nice kick, Batman.
Ugh.
There's no way he built this by himself.
Okay.
Jason Mamoa built it painted thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you
oh yeah Alfred be super I saw I've seen that comic before he
got like kryptonite like those like you know like those like
mob wrist brace or whatever and but then it's like
kryptonite
because Alfred does not have the engineer degree to build a
fucking bad cave
I refuse to believe that he has the degree to fucking...
The engineer degree to build a back gate.
Where do I go from here?
Sure he does.
Guys, I know you're all Alfred fanboys.
But like, you guys have to think real fast.
Guys, think for a second, please.
He can get one.
Yes, but that doesn't mean he's qualified to fucking build a
bat cave.
Alfred's Mike Kamioshi.
It's true, I just googled it.
Then that makes me less trustworthy of the bat cave.
He doesn't even have a degree for this.
How can I trust him to build a fucking structure in a cave?
Alfred's a homie.
Well, he's fucking dead.
Do you not remember what I established?
He's been dead for five years.
Here I go.
I'm called for.
Here?
I'm just back here.
Isn't this the original cave?
No, this is different.
Too soon.
Oh, no, this is different.
You guys had to know this sooner or later.
Because I've said it during the part one.
He won't be when they reboot it.
Okay, that's true.
That's true.
You're not wrong.
You're not wrong, guys.
Don't worry.
When they reboot it.
That man literally chose to build a getaway home under
asylum.
Yes, but who?
There's no way Bruce Wayne built this by himself.
I refuse to believe Bruce Wayne built this by himself.
He doesn't have...
He didn't even finish school.
He went and learned martial arts.
Lucius Fox is underrated.
with the gadgets and stuff yeah they really get one guy to
build the fucking oh my god it's time to fist this plant he
filed some tools like now i'm scared because he's more
likely to build a sinkhole they won't get that far my
antidote will stop them all
right go keep please he's a billionaire
even the bat cave that's fucked up okay that's fucked up
that he got two like elderly people to build his fucking
home unfortunately unfortunately nothing that simple I'm at
the main sewer junction and appears to be polluted with
Titan I feel like that's even worse what's he doing now oh
shit fist fist All right, ow.
Where do I go?
Where am I?
Okay, I need to figure out how to get up there.
Where are the plants?
He made kids build his fucking game?
Like I said, Robbins.
Help with building.
Bro, the elderly and the kids?
We need to stop him.
Somebody saw Batman.
Alright, I think it's like...
Am I close to the fucking area yet?
No, I have to get head up.
No.
Who's gonna stop him, Joker?
No one can stop him.
Game that, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you!
Batman Facts.
Batman builds a Batman with the help of Alfred, Robin, and
Harold.
Batman's tech guide.
Wayne tells a construction cool he's building a scenic cave,
and then they haul it out and assemble the mechanical bits.
But this
time, it's full of Titan.
How do I stop it?
Oh my god, he's gonna poison the water supply again.
Also, thank you, and Super Chat.
Yeah, I want to read.
Thank you.
I can't believe it!
He got kids and the other He's gonna stop him!
Alright, fist.
Why does this look like a...
Why does this cave shape like a bat?
Hmm.
Wee.
That's weird.
Ow.
Where did I go?
This way?
Where the fuck is he?
God, there's so many areas.
They go the wrong way?
This way?
Bro, where the fuck is the exit?
Okay, it's like here.
It's below me, I think.
Yeah, it's right here.
Okay, thank God.
I...
This was where I came from This is I got, thank God Fucking,
alright, let's do this Again I No, no No I don't like it
down I don't fucking It's, I went down Oh my god I can't
believe I went down.
This is... It's because I'm on Wi-Fi.
Even my fucking brain cells have gone down with the Wi-Fi.
Gamers don't look up, Cos.
No!
Cosic!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Back in the beginning?
Okay, I can fast travel.
I can, like, speedrun this.
I blame the Wi-Fi.
If I wasn't on Wi-Fi, things would be easier it's never my
fault it's the wi-fi's fault all right here we go
this way then we go up just don't fall please batman do not
fall up i go okay oh my god that's where the up was i think
i noticed the up now i noticed it it's up here it's up here
guys i figured it out
i'll shut them all down what will happen if this titan stuff
reaches gotham
i'm so sad chong thank you super chat thank you thank you on
this episode doki gets lost again Okay.
Where?
Here.
Alright.
Spoop.
Weeeeee!
Oh, thank god there's a Riller trophy to tell me where.
Joker?
Is that Joker?
Joker, please!
Let me listen to your voice so I don't get lied!
How the fuck do I get up there?
Can I...
Can I do it from...
With the claw?
Wait.
Oh!
Nice.
Back claw time.
Yay!
Come over here!
Make a... Make a bridge!
I mean, I could do this.
Make a bridge for me!
God damn it, I wanted them to make a bridge.
Wait, how the...
How the fuck do I get over there still?
Instructions unclear.
Alright.
Obviously not this.
Drapa and...
Can I grapple up now?
Oh, now I can.
Okay.
I didn't realize I can grapple now.
Yes.
Yay.
Wow, what the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Holy shit.
I'm so blind.
All right, so thank you for the five.
Give the ship thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, for the love of...
I suppose that's you in there, Bat.
Well, enjoy it while you can.
These caves will be...
wait he stopped moving just like me when i was on the wi-fi
all right up we go open the door don't worry i have this
whoop whoop Yay!
Concussion!
Nice.
I'm happy now.
And you're calm.
Teeth!
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
That's a lot of things.
Basko, thank you for super chat thank you thank you joki
what cp model do you use i know uh are having stability
issues due to an optimized bias setting maybe a mem test as
well you may want to get your settings check great stream by
the way um good question teeth
all right let's see where do i go Do they see me?
Wait.
Not my crutch.
But there's a gargoyle.
It's not my crutch, I swear.
But now I got the gargoyle.
Gargoyle!
Oh, I don't think he saw me.
Goodbye!
Hey, get off me!
Nice.
Gargoyle!
Where are you?
Yay!
Okay, wait, I can do this again.
I can do this again.
Here I go again.
Gargoyle!
Of any gargoyles can I get away with?
Come on!
Let me make my pile!
My gargoyle pile.
This...
My gargoyle pile!
Okay, I'll put it here.
No!
My gargoyle pile!
Go!
there I'm sure it came from over there yes right here right
here yes go to the pile goodbye don't look up don't look up
though just head to the pile sure it came from over there
just head to the pile you know you want to come on whoops
get the pile i'm sure it came from over there yes it did not
up there fucking god i'm fucking gonna kill him dude fuck
this my beautiful pile maybe there's still one more there's
still one more he'll eventually come over here right come to
the pile please report to the pile it's so cool you know i'm
like this pile this is my new pile my new pile oh shit oh
shit there's one more we have whoa guys there was a lot of
people still
alive if it works it works there's a lot that's okay one HP
in the dream again I made a new pile
File number two.
My pile.
Alright, what was the riddle for this?
Riddle me this.
Oh, hey, there's a thing here.
See, I think it was super chat.
I think the concussion won't kill him, but the medical...
That's what I'm saying.
Like, this is much worse than, like, not killing.
Because now you're giving him, like, medical debt.
In America.
And I'm pretty sure, like, because, like, it's a superhero
area, too.
So, like, the insurance is, like, even worse than normal
insurance.
And I feel like the meta...
Oh, my gosh.
Being a doctor must be so fucking nice.
Because all the people that are, like, need doctors.
Riddling me this.
Wait, that's why Batman owns, like, a pharmacy.
Do you guys know Batman also owns a pharmacy?
Oh my god!
That's so fucked up, Batman.
Batman, that's pretty fucked up.
He is part of the problem.
He is actually part of the problem.
Holy shit.
I never realized that.
Anything to scan here?
It all adds up.
Oh yeah.
I mean okay it's time for hacking time okay where's the
other one nice two last one oh no why is the last one always
the hardest where is it oh here is nice the Batman infinite
money glitch.
It's like the infinite chocolate glitch, but for money.
Nice.
How do I solve this riddle?
What was this riddle again?
What was this one's riddle?
Blow up the floor?
No, there's nothing there.
No, Batman doesn't own everything.
Because for some fucking reason, Gotham has like 200 fucking
billionaires that live here.
Like every villain is either... Every villain or hero here
is either...
It's either a billionaire, villain, or a billionaire hero.
What?
I hear people.
Oh, there they are.
It's a new Silicon Valley.
Alright.
Hoop, hoop.
Oh, wait, that's not what I wanted.
Hoop.
There we go.
Get down over here.
Nice.
There's a vent.
It's in the vent.
vent?
The ridder?
Okay, is it in this vent?
Ow, sorry.
Where's the ridder?
What's this?
Where am I?
I don't know where I am.
Where's this place?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, I'm in this other event area.
Gotham City is either where all the rich people live.
or all the poor people if there's no middle class in Gotham
City.
You just think about it.
Alright.
I don't know where the riddle is for this one.
Oh well.
I think we have to go back this way.
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I swear to God.
I swear to fucking God.
My Wi-Fi.
Wi-Fi, why you must do this to me, Wi-Fi.
Oh,
you fuck.
Please, let me beat Batman.
That's all I want.
I'm so close to beating Batman.
Oh, my God.
I'm so fucking close.
Oh my god No, it's just Okay, I'm back Okay, I'm back I'm
fucking back I swear to fucking god Wi-Fi, please Please
Wi-Fi Here we go That should be it Is this?
No?
Here we go Oh my god, Wi-Fi
So Batman have time to beat up I crashed
That's like a game I will beat you I will beat you Batman I
will beat you So I never have to deal with this again Oh my
god Damn you Jason Bomo You know thank you for the Super
chat thingy thank you are you sure Thank you the Super chat
Alan thank you for the Super chat Thank you Thank you.
Sounds like Mexico.
Alright, here we go.
No!
We will beat Batman!
So, don't do part four!
And deal with this another day.
Here we go.
This is it.
Where am I?
I swear...
Okay, thank God I...
Oh, thank fucking God.
I was gonna say, I swear to God if I have to do that one
area again.
Okay.
Come on, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tomato PC upgrade fun.
Okay, it's either getting hurt by Batman or getting hurt.
I feel like I would get hurt by Joker rather than...
No, get hurt by Batman rather than Joker.
But Joker would actually make it slow and painful.
Heat.
The year is 2055.
Doki is finally at the 5th.
10% of Batman.
Would this be the year?
Dad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, I just need to get this guy.
No, I need you to get the guy with the gun!
The gun!
Oh my god.
I'll just kill him.
Ow!
It's the gun!
The gun guy!
Ow.
Okay, it's fine.
I got the gun.
It's okay.
We got the gun.
We got the gun, guys.
That's okay.
Okay.
We're good.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Panda, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Jesus Christ!
Get away!
No,
no, no, no, no!
Okay.
Got it countered correctly.
Nice, alright.
Get him out.
No, what?
Are you- what?
I countered it!
I swear.
I know I got shinked.
I got fucking shinked.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I got shaked.
Okay, I'll use the remote control.
You know what?
No, I have an idea.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
What are you gonna do now?
Nothing!
That's right.
You can't do it.
Whoa!
Yeah, I forgot he had.
Sorry, I forgot he had a gun.
I forgot he had a gun, guys.
There's no way I think I can I think I can kill it them with
a bat around
There you I think I can kill him with the bat around
There you go Right No, they're they're all very alive.
They're all they're all very alive guys All right, we can do
this.
Okay, we can...
We can do this.
Okay, we can we can totally do this.
Okay, here we go.
God damn it, we can do this.
All right, get over here, gun!
Gun!
There you go.
It's fine.
I told you we could do this.
I told you!
Come on.
Dodge!
There, he can't get another gun!
I told you!
Ah, you shake me!
Alright, this is not good though.
The shake is not good.
Okay, nice.
I messed up the combo for that, but that's okay.
That's alright.
And I dodge, it's okay, I still have plenty of HP.
Nope!
No shanking, no shanking, no shanking.
Oh shit!
No gun?
Yeah, I think he's okay Don't worry I think he'll be okay
See I told you!
I got this!
Nope, no gun There we go, watch
Easy first try Nice.
We did it.
Alright.
And then...
Is it hacking time?
Hacking time.
Time to play on my phone.
Time to play on my PSP.
Oh.
PSP?
This is why PSP was discontinued.
Surely they have healthcare in Gotham.
Thank you, Ken.
Thank you.
Super chat.
All right, another hacker man.
Hacker man time.
That's pump three disabled.
I'm going to head back up to the surface and track down IV.
Get in touch if you need anything, bro.
Yeah, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Doki.
Have you heard of the legend of the mad and his ventures at
the ham asylum?
Welcome to the madhouse.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, where do we go?
Oh, wait.
I can upgrade.
All right, what to upgrade?
Oh, I'm going to upgrade.
I'm like, I think I'm gonna help grade.
Triple Batterangs!
Turn to overload.
Getting camped however the Rizu won't stop any further aside
from being effective in this location.
Wait, what do we do?
Far right?
Which one?
The Sonic Shock?
Sonic Batteram Blast?
This one?
Alright, we'll try that.
Uh, Barrett, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Love from the Nico Nation.
You know Nico from four years ago.
Happy to see you guys playing in some time.
Love it.
You're hilarious.
My best to try and go.
Thank you.
I'm glad you enjoyed that stream.
I've been, like, bumping into, like, a lot of fucking, like,
not fan interactions, but, like, a lot of random
interaction.
It's been funny.
The amount of random interactions I've been getting in
voice.
Nico Maioshi.
He's not even single!
Wait, oh wait, there's something over there.
What's that?
Oh, there's tape.
I can love him from a fire!
If you see him, you wait long enough, he will eventually be
seen.
Guys, guys, please love yourself.
Nico, my Oshi platonically.
He's just a bro, Doki.
Yay, teeth.
uh let's see oh what a bro sheet exactly a bro sheet what
are you sending where is it where is the joker is it in here
oh oh there he is
Hello.
Wait, he can dodge that?
Oh, nice.
Can I?
Damn.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa!
Okay, its okay, there's friendly fire.
Remember our friendly fire strat?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that was unfortunate, though.
That was actually unfortunate.
Okay.
Get over here.
It's friendly fire time.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Yeah!
Get over here!
Get into the electricity!
Nice.
Free hit.
Free combo.
Okay, that should, like, actually kill them.
Like, that's a slap from this guy.
Like, Come on.
He slaps pretty fucking hard.
Come on.
That should have been like easily a fucking...
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
I have so much HP.
Ow!
Okay.
Mipi not okay.
Mipi...
Oh, shit.
Mipi is not okay.
Fuck.
Okay, I'm going to run into electricity.
All right, it's fine.
We're fine.
There's more?
Oh, my God.
There's more.
How is there more?
Oh, no.
I didn't expect there to be more.
Woo!
Please leave me.
me alone please leave me alone whoa okay okay oh no is he
gonna throw bodies at me again too no oh fuck okay he did
yep yep he did no nice nice no what it's not fair that's not
fair that's not No, no, no, let me dodge.
Let me dodge.
Oh, God.
Oh, it's a 1 HP and a dream again.
Wow.
Please hurt each other.
Please.
Yes.
Please just hurt each other.
That's all I want.
Yes, okay.
Just keep hurting each other.
Woo!
Okay.
No, keep charging.
Keep charging.
It's just there.
No, no, no.
Don't use your bodies.
Do not use the bodies.
Come on.
Bowling, bowling, bowling, bowling, bowling.
Yes.
Yes, bowling.
Oh, God.
We can do this again.
No, no, no.
Keep bowling.
The bowling will work eventually.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
That's a human dodgeball.
It's human dodgeball time.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Whoa!
Okay.
Yes!
Oh, shit, there's too many dodgeballs.
There's too many bowling pins.
What do I do?
Oh, fuck you.
There's too many bowling pins.
Oh, my God.
I'm getting expected to be more.
Oh, please, eventually.
okay all right technique oh my god eventually eventually
whoa
okay eventually there'll be less people right there can't be
people forever there's no way
No, please, please all this human dodgeball Wow, they're
infinite until you kill the giant Okay, okay, this is
unfortunate This is very unfortunate because this is very
difficult No, oh my god, no Oh, please This is so difficult
to dodge I
I'm so sad we killed each other I'm so sad we killed each
other but it didn't count Oh my god, I can't believe it
didn't count I can't believe it We were so close we're
actually so close oh my god what happened i can't believe it
oh my god wrong one i can't believe we were so close
no not the no oh my god please let me on no not you i don't
care about you oh my god okay there you go uh no no no can't
head into the electricity get into the electricity i don't
care about the people
please if i don't kill them it'd be easier
Oh my god.
It'd be easier because there'd be less people to worry
about.
Oh no, please.
Please, I beg of you.
Do not do this to me.
Okay.
I beg of you.
I beg of you, please.
Okay.
Please.
Dodge.
Oh, dodge, please.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Do not open the elevator.
There's still people alive.
Yes.
All right.
Oh, no.
They're going to open the elevator.
Not the elevator.
No!
Not the fucking elevator!
It's okay.
Everything will be okay.
Please.
Oh no, not the fucking dodgeball.
Okay.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy right now.
No!
Okay!
strategic tank.
Ow.
It's a strategic tank.
It's strategic.
Please don't open the elevator.
Please, there's still people alive.
There's still people alive.
Okay.
Charge, charge, charge, charge, charge.
Woo!
What?
Alright, that was bullshit, though.
That was actually bullshit.
Okay.
Please, let me- let me on him!
Let me on him, you!
Please!
Okay.
Get away from me!
Oh my god.
Get the fuck away from me.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
You guys lied to me!
You guys said they'll keep coming!
But there's clearly...
They clearly come!
Keep coming no matter what!
I can't believe I got the one guide again.
I can't believe it.
I got one guide.
Oh my god.
I got one guide so hard.
They would always exist.
But at least it's easier now.
At least it's so much easier now.
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god.
We're so close.
Get out of here.
Get the fuck out of here.
Leave me alone.
Leave me the fuck alone.
Nice.
Boom!
There you go.
We did it.
Oh, we fucking did it.
Please, please, where's my HP recharge?
Why is it my HP recharge?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, my HP recharge.
We go this way.
Okay.
Alright, we do this.
Get down.
Archie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for making me laugh so much on my birthday.
great time.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Archie.
Yeah!
Alright, where am I?
Okay, above.
Here we go.
Games.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're gonna try and hit you.
My advice is you don't... I...
okay give me
don't worry we're gonna be back soon we're gonna be back
soon oh my god wi-fi why are you like this wi-fi why are you
like this wi-fi
please please what have i done to you other than never use
you i'm fine why all right here we go we're back in it
there's apparently a scan downstairs anyway there is like
here where's the scan at ow scan it we're not scan liars the
scuff is so strong oh here it's like right here the island
changed little over the years its reputation was in tatters
but i vowed to fix it as the buildings were rebuilt i saw
the future a bright wonderful future Glad so.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You've got actually several hours of the game left, by the
way.
So it's okay to stop here if need be.
Is he lying?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is he lying or is he speaking the truth?
How much more do I have?
I need to know.
How much more?
He's lying.
Okay.
Now I don't know if you guys are lying now.
Ah, fuck, okay.
I still have two boss battles left.
One, at least two?
Like, 1.5?
Three hours?
Three hours.
I can do that.
That's fucking easy.
Okay, I need to figure out how to do this, though.
How the fuck do I do this?
Oh, wait.
I tag it.
I forgot.
I have the tag.
Boop.
this is fine okay i'm gonna tag myself too i forgot how to
how many
crashes and those don't say that please don't
don't say that what do you mean how many crashes so good No!
Alright.
We'll get out of this area.
We'll do the last part.
We'll do the last part another time.
We need to get outside.
Okay, we'll get outside and then we'll call it here.
Alright.
Now we're outside.
Wait, is that...
That saved?
Okay.
That might be getting stronger.
We'll go to the next area and then we'll call it here.
We'll go to the next area.
You'll be walking into a trap.
That's what she thinks.
Oh wait, actually we can like do this.
Let's go to the...
Uh, let's go to the...
Easter egg first.
Twist!
This island belongs to me now.
Oh, is that Ivy?
It almost says literally an hour.
I don't...
Oh shit, there's four of you guys!
You know, I think that's a good time to call it.
It's alright.
The game decided this is where I'm ending.
It's okay.
The game...
We let the game decide.
We let...
It's okay, guys.
We just let the game decide to call me a year.
Like a game said, the stream is over.
Oh my god.
Zonerman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He was like, no, we're done, Doki.
We are done here.
We're super fucking done here.
There's no last one.
oh my god for the wild ride i read a lot of super chess as
we came in so um we'll do we'll i need to figure out what
the fuck happened to my fucking to my cable because well i'm
only on wi-fi right now for some fucking reason even the
game was like no no no dokey this is it i really want to
finish it today too i i knew i could finish it today but we
were crashing way too we were they were they were fucking it
was not the good time the game was like no no no and also
the fact that i'm on wi-fi i feel like we just had to stop
um but yeah had a great time i hope you guys had a great
time um watching and uh watching today and hanging out with
me it was definitely a really fun time next week i believe
there's two week um we're gonna be playing uh hell divers 2
again but this time with a group um look forward to who it
is um but yes it's gonna be a full party for next week's
hell divers uh hell divers 2 and then uh we're also gonna
i'm still trying to plan uh uh lily and i are still planning
a collab for next week we're still deciding what to do uh so
i'm gonna figure that out as well later uh tomorrow Sunday
and I usually don't stream on Sunday so tomorrow is a break
day for me also on next Saturday on March not March March
2nd will be our stream auction slash charity I'm really
really excited because there's a lot of really amazing
things being auctioned off a lot of these items are one of a
kind um they are one of a kind uh items such as I can
actually give you guys an example a one-of-a-kind figure
that it's like that's like um uh that's that's like printed
and then sent off to japan to have it painted and everything
and they were actually sent me like some concept art of it
so like this is like a one-of-a-kind figure that's gonna be
auctioned off and i'm super duper excited too i thought like
they sent me a concept art and like being like okay like you
want to pick this or that i was like wow but like i'll show
you guys a preview but yeah this is gonna be in the auction
um a lot of like amazing stuff so um but they let me chose i
chose number one i chose one um for it and this is gonna be
set off to japan to have it like fully painted and
everything before shipped over to whoever wins the auction
um but yeah uh that's like some of the stuff to look forward
to um but yeah thank you everybody hope you guys had a fun
time watching we will finish Batman next time like next week
for real I legit would have been able to finish it today if
everything that everything that didn't if I didn't go
through so many things that went wrong today I would have
finished it today it was so close we were so close to
finishing it today but anyway thank you everybody for coming
as always everyone stay hydrated posture check blood flowing
interviews stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it
i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye